That we will explore today is in many
ways what I'm trying to figure out some
of the deepest implications of what it
means to be a human being.
When we first formed the ocf worth our
fellowship last year,
one of the discussion,
one of the very first discussions we had
at our weekly meeting was one that dealt
with how we see ourselves today,
how we in our society and especially as
students have lost something very sacred
about ourselves and many currents of
thought annual.
Certainly in our hyper rationalized
deconstructed postmodern world,
one loses sight of the meaning of not
only those things which are external to
us,
but in the process we fail to understand
the very core of Rv.
Many of you will know that recently Dr.
Jordan Peterson has faced an amended set
of controversy precisely for questioning
the dogmas of our age and yet he has
also stressed the importance of the
divine individual and the Christian
concept of the logos,
which I will allow our speakers to
elaborate upon today.
A dear friend had told me once that one
fundamentally divides orthodoxy from any
other kind of videology is precisely
this,
the dignity of the divine individual and
what this means for us as spiritual and
physical beings.
And so I'm immensely excited to be here.
One are timeless,
have to say the ninth.
And so I'd like to introduce each of our
panelists starting with Father Theodore
across govopoly is uh,
who is adjunct faculty of the Orthodox
School of theology at the Trinity
College.
Uh,
last semester he taught a course on the
human person in Orthodox theology and
Orthodox tradition.
And in many ways it's something that
touches upon orange,
reduces the very core of what's being
discussed today,
what is the individual,
what does it mean to be human?
And he is also quite a positive presence
at our institution fellowship and we
certainly look forward to hearing his
perspective tonight.
Jonathon Hijo is a very well known icon
carver from Quebec as well as an editor
for the Orthodox Arts Journal.
Many of us were familiar with the
Jonathan and his work prior to this and
so it was a great pleasure to have him
here tonight and indeed it is entirely
appropriate.
Just this past Sunday,
the Orthodox Church celebrated in the
spirit of unity,
the Sunday of Orthodoxy,
the celebration of our triumph over
iconoclasm.
The tradition of iconography in the
orthodox tradition is one of the
theology and I'm very pleased at an
expert on the matter is with us here
today and many of you may be interested
to hear Jonathan's online discussion
with Dr. Peters and uh,
the most recent one being concerned with
one of the most controversial political
symbols of this day,
the metaphysics of Pepe,
Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson is a professor of psychology
here at the University of Toronto.
And I think it goes without saying that
the activism of Dr. Peterson has
inspired many in the room today.
Manny,
who would have previously perhaps not
even considered looking into the type of
concepts which are going to be
discussing today.
Myself and many others have been deeply
moved by not only Dr Peterson's insight
on matters of a political nature,
but also in his insight in human nature.
The title of this discussion was
influenced by Dr Peterson's usage of the
constant of the Christian concept of
logos and what that means for us as
individuals.
I'd like to thank Dr. Peters and for
joining us and we are greatly looking
forward to hearing more of your insight
on this map.
Last but not least,
Father Jeffrey Ready,
who was a co director of the Orthodox
School of theology.
Uh,
the chaplain of Orthodox Christian
Fellowship and the parish priest at the
holy mirror is Orthodox mission,
uh,
located at Trinity Chapel from the very
creation of our ocs last year on the
Jeff.
He has continuously blown our minds and
enhanced our understanding not only of
our orthodox spiritual life,
but of ourselves as human beings.
Apart from his remarkable Pesaro
qualities,
his wealth of knowledge and perspective
has made it only natural that we would
offer his perspective on this panel
tonight.
I'd like to thank all the Jeffrey for
his work and great league.
Look forward to hearing his perspectives
tonight.
So the format for the discussion today
will be basically that each of our
panelists will speak for for a time and
this will be followed by a question and
answer period.
Each of you will have received a few
hard,
um,
and each row has about two ends.
So for the duration of the discussion,
you can write down your questions and
pass them up at the front and then we'll
try to get through as many of as
possible by the end of the night.
And with that,
I like to welcome Father Theodore Cross,
give off lists to the podium to begin
our discussion.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
okay,
so there's not gonna be any mind
blowing.
Okay.
That's reserved for Father Jeffrey.
Thank you to the ocf at uft for asking
me to come and to be up here on the
stage with people that I kind of feel I
feel outclassed.
Definitely.
Let's,
um,
I appreciate the invitation.
Uh,
so I was told to speak for like 10 to 15
minutes about what it means to be a
human person in the orthodox tradition.
So I don't know how possible that is.
Um,
but live just mentioned that,
uh,
in the past,
two days on Sunday,
we celebrated any of the Orthodox
tradition,
the Sunday of Orthodoxy,
which is the first Sunday in lent.
Uh,
for those of you who don't know what
that is or don't know,
we'll be celebrating that day,
we celebrate the return of the holy
icons into the church.
Now,
a lot of people who've been to Orthodox
churches know that the church is full of
icons and they wonder,
well,
when was there a turn and why was there
a return considering,
you know,
to be ever not have.
Though of course,
Christians have had images in their
churches and in their places of worship
from the very beginning.
But there was a time that,
um,
there was an impression of the idea of
using images as a,
and it was considered for the idolatry,
you from the church.
And there was a faction within the
church that I'm a font against this.
And for almost a hundred years,
a icons were burned,
destroyed,
and taken out of churches.
And it was only with the seventh
Ecumenical Council,
uh,
that they were returned.
Of course.
Why did we celebrate this on Sunday of
Orthodoxy?
And what'd we call it,
Sunday of Orthodoxy is because those who
are the proponents of icons,
and of course all modern Orthodox
Christians today knew that the attack on
the depiction of Christ was an attack on
the incarnation itself.
Um,
the idea that Christ is an actual mean
actually existed actually live and
lives.
He was an actual historical figure who
live at a certain time and not a figment
of our imagination as some people today
would say.
And this means that when we speak about
God and when we speak about the trinity,
when you speak about the second person
of the Trinity,
who is the son,
the locals,
um,
as we were speaking about tonight,
uh,
we are speaking about a very specific
person.
And,
uh,
that is in contrast to many of the
discussions that we see today,
both in the Public Forum online,
uh,
that's symposia like this,
where we,
where many people would like to think of
God as an abstract for Orthodox
Christians.
And I would say for,
you know,
historical ancient Christianity,
God is not an aspect that either God is
an actual person,
there's an objective reality,
their prices and objective person,
he thinks a certain way,
speaks a certain way,
act a certain way,
even looked a certain way,
and so we can depict an,
an icon.
Now,
the reason why I started with this and I
kind of,
you know,
uh,
begin,
my thoughts is a because there is a
little bit of a contrast between many
religions and orthodoxy.
Uh,
this is not,
this is a generalization,
but as generalizations go in many
religions,
whether they be Christian or not,
um,
the concept of God or the concept of the
divine usually centers around the idea
of the word of God.
When the concept of God made text,
and there are usually writings about
this and writings that are usually very
ancient,
they're passed down.
And the text is usually what is focused
on even amongst many Christian
denominations,
it's all about the text.
However,
in the orthodox tradition,
it is not about the word defending text,
but rather about the word becoming
flesh.
I mean human being.
And so our faith is not based on a text
of rather on a deep mystical experience
of the risen Lord throughout time.
Are you going to say,
well,
we read the Bible too,
right?
We use the Bible,
we venerate the Bible.
We have it in very high regard.
However,
for ancient Christianity,
I love that cause I like star trek too.
Um,
um,
when we,
uh,
when we speak about Christ and you speak
about God,
we speak about a living tradition,
Christ and found a bull.
Neither did he found the philosophy,
but rather he found it a very real
community,
a living community.
And the Orthodox Church,
the last 2000 years is this living
community that has never stopped with,
has never ceased to exist.
It was never a time where he did not
exist.
Um,
we have no beginning.
We have no reformer,
we have no sounder.
Uh,
we have no school of thoughts,
but rather a,
we exist from the very beginning.
So the reason why I say this is because
our concept of God and our concept of
our relationship to him is a very
intimate one.
And one that is in living for the last
2000 years.
So,
okay,
going back to the idea of an
incarnational theology and have icons,
uh,
if we are just saying that God is real,
he actually exists.
If we don't believe in that more than
this talk doesn't really matter.
But if we believe that God exists and
that God is an actual person is a mine,
his personality and that is Christ is
God in human form,
then uh,
the reality is is that there is an
objective reality to who god is.
And by that we can say that there's an
objective truth that'd be can speak
about.
And there is an objective good that we
can speak about.
And there is an objective understanding
of the human being.
It is not subjective but rather
objective.
And for us as Orthodox Christians,
we tend to follow the model that was
coined by seeing nothing else.
The grades,
same as fourth century father,
the church,
every theologian who said that God
became man so that we may become God,
not that we need to come,
you'll God's like gone.
So for us,
the goal of the Christian life is to
emulate,
right?
It's to become Christ light.
It's not about what I think of myself as
a lot about why I want to be or what
would I would like to create in my mind
what I would like to be or what I think
I am,
but rather that there is Christ and
Christ is the perfect human being.
And I tried to discover what that is and
I know that is diametrically opposed to
the society that we live in today.
For the most part,
for the most part,
that we live in a society that is a
society of subjectivity,
not object.
And we live in a society that when he
speaks about religion,
speaks about spirituality in a speech
about,
speaks about theology.
It usually refers to the subjective
understanding of God,
the subjective understanding of the
human person as Professor Peterson has
in the last few months.
Um,
so when we talk about human identity,
it is,
um,
it is something that is to be discovered
and not to be kind of created or self
created.
So,
you know,
there's a,
there's a writing at a very early second
century writing in the church called the
heat,
which means the teaching,
uh,
one of the earliest writings of the
church I guess we could say is one of
the earliest manuals,
um,
uh,
of how to be a Christian or the basics
of the Christian faith,
I guess you could say.
And in the that he,
it says the first line says there are
two ways,
um,
one of life I want to death and there's
a great difference between the two is
the opening lines and a,
and really when it comes to,
you know,
the,
uh,
the understanding of the human person
from Orthodox point of view,
we would say the same thing.
That there are really two ways to
understand.
There is either the revelation from God
and how we emulate that or rather
there's the movement towards the south
towards self revelation,
self understanding.
And really,
uh,
we would say,
um,
self idealization and uh,
and soul of course we as human beings
are free to do whatever we wanted to do.
Um,
and we have free will.
But how we use that and what we're,
what do you do with it?
And what you choose to become really
depends on where we're looking for
words,
what do we want it to do and then,
and who we want to be.
So I would say that the,
the modern existential crisis of our
time can really be remedied by the
simple statement that if there is a god,
there's a God,
I'm not him.
So the understanding of that,
if there's a god and I'm not,
that him would mean that I need to
discover who that God is and what he
expects of me.
Why am I here and what am I supposed to
do with my life?
And that's diametrically opposed to the
subjective understanding of that God is
whatever I wanted to do or what I would
rather him eat and go from there.
So in pre modern Western civilization,
um,
society was predominantly,
you know,
society of these kinds of values.
It's kind of objective truths.
Uh,
it was kind of like the social glue that
provided stability for the family and
social institutions and religion and,
uh,
and even business ethics.
Like people believe that there was a
good,
there was a truth out there that we need
to discovered.
There was a god that we needed to
somehow figure out who that God was.
Um,
and the humility that was required to
set that we are not gods,
uh,
was what held all that together and the
social and psychological fabric of
society.
So without it,
and this is where I think,
um,
as a peterson would also agree in has
said many times without this kind of a
understanding of an objective reality,
um,
there is an endless movement towards the
individuals word,
subjectivities,
tours,
what is relative and ultimately towards
nihilism.
Because if there is no objective meaning
in life and there's no objective truth
in life,
then everything is whatever I made it
and everybody has right?
And really everybody is wrong.
And then really what you have to listen
for.
So real ultimate meaning life.
And so this is the problem,
you know,
and then there's a movement towards the
delusion that everyone has their own God
and everyone is free to create
themselves in their own image.
And this breeds and this fragmentation
as professor [inaudible] said,
a volt,
socal individual truths and also
individual identities.
So
if there is no god,
as we said,
this conversation doesn't really matter.
However,
if there is a god and he has a personal
God as a Christian his claim,
then we cannot go on ignoring him
without suffering a serious identity
crisis.
I believe that this crisis has arrived.
And the question is how do we as
Christians continued to see the world,
see the word of God,
the divine logos in those who refuse to
see it in themselves?
Like how do we speak to that?
How do we speak to a world that doesn't
even
acknowledge that there is such a locals?
But there is such a truth in the first
place.
This is,
this is the conundrum that we find
ourselves in the difficulty.
How do we witness to a world that is not
speaking the same language anymore?
And I think that is uh,
something that,
uh,
you know,
discussions like this are,
are super important and attend the first
steps.
Because here we are attempting and I,
and I applaud the ocf for doing this,
attempting to find points of convergence
between a Christian tradition,
Orthodox Christian tradition and also
um,
the secular approach,
psychology,
sociology,
history,
biology,
places where these things converge and
they'd tell us and they preach the same
truth.
And this is why I was so enthused about
coming and speaking today because
watching a lot of Festo Peterson's,
uh,
videos online,
I saw that there are a lot of points
that he makes that not only are
congruent with Orthodox theology and
Orthodox anthropology,
but speak common sense to the world in a
world that is completely fragmented,
a world that is completely disengaged
from the idea that there can be a truth
outside of ourselves and that there
needs to be some type of seeking,
some type of understanding of what that
truth may be.
The main difference between philosophy
and theology I always tell my students
is,
is that philosophy comes from us.
It is us trying to understand the world,
trying to understand the metaphysical,
try,
understand glaad punters stand,
anything you can philosophize about
anyway,
but the source of the human being,
we have this wonderful thing called the
mind is so powerful.
They can do so many things,
but that's philosophy.
Theology heals with a revelation.
He was with what has been revealed from
outside the community of someone else
and that's what,
that's what the church has to deal with
it.
That's what the Christian,
what does Shanti has to deal with the
idea of what God has revealed in himself
by becoming a real movie,
becoming one of us have.
We can't negate that as much as we try
and to do so would mean to negate an
important part of ourselves because we
believe as tuition is like the say all
the time and as would like to quote
genesis where God says in the very
beginning,
genesis one 26 God makes man in his
image and his likeness.
He gives us this great ability to shoots
great of his ability to reason and to
figure things out for ourselves and to
decide whether we want to be like him or
whether we want to be more like
something else.
So this is the great dilemma.
It's not just a theological dilemma,
it's not just a spiritual dilemma,
but it's an existential dilemma and it's
becoming social dilemma.
You tell me a political dilemma I
biological dilemma and a whole lot of
other climbers.
So I will end there.
Um,
I will let a folly Jonathan take it from
here,
but I think this is a general
introduction to at least the way we see
it as Orthodox Christians,
that God becomes man so that man can
become God.
The words of the Apostle Paul,
there's lot I who live but Christ who
lives within.
And this is our,
our ultimate hope.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
did.
Thanks cory.
Appreciate it.
I appreciate being here.
I appreciate it.
Being in Toronto,
it's a great town.
Today I spent the day going to the
museum and visiting,
so I really enjoying the city.
I'm going to start with this story.
Um,
it's March,
2015 and uh,
I'm driving good to pick up my children
at some friend's house on Friday night
and it's about half an hour drive.
So I'm settling in and I'm listening to
the CBC like I usually do.
Would that particular evening,
the content is not usually what you get
on the CDC.
So on the air,
this University of Toronto professor and
what are you saying rings a bit off from
what I usually hear on that show.
And at first he's talking about religion
and religious symbolism and he's doing
it in a way,
let's say he's doing it without the
usual smugness that we tend to hear when
people talk about religion,
especially about Christianity.
And so here he is talking about
Christianity,
but I can tell he's not,
you're not a priest,
he's not a preacher,
he's a psychologist,
he's a scientist.
And so as a talk on folds my,
let's say my attention heightens,
and after a few minutes,
just a few minutes,
I just,
I can't believe what I'm hearing as this
profits is going to stories of Adam and
Eve,
Cain and Abel jumping to Shakespeare and
Milton and Jerky and then to Darwin and
Nietzsche and you'll and,
and immediately I see what he's doing.
He has,
I'm just trying to communicate
information.
He's dancing across this wide variety of
references because what's wants to do is
he wants to bring out,
he wants to trace this underlying
pattern
and by doing so he's trying to awaken
something in his listeners.
He's not just trying to get them to
understand,
which is what we usually hear when we
listened to talks.
No,
he's trying to provoke,
like to shake people into experiencing
how the world is built with meaning.
Okay.
So he talks about logos,
which is true,
meaning express in words.
This search for purpose and logos,
transforms,
transforms chaos and potentiality and to
being and in opposition to this lies,
deceit,
resentment,
gradually dismantle the world and plunge
it into ever-growing chaos.
I mean,
of course he's taking this from the
Bible,
the Book of Genesis from the Gospel of
Saint John Sprinkled with some
phenomenology,
but he's very clearly describing this
process at all levels of reality
at the individual.
The interpersonal is social,
political levels and this interaction
between logos and chaos is the main
manner we could say by which the world
is constantly sustained.
So by this point,
I am,
I literally cheering in the car.
I'm like,
I'm hitting my steering wheel.
And all I can think is who is this?
Who is this person talking and why have
I not heard of him before?
Like why is he not famous?
I guess we don't ask that question
anymore.
Right?
And especially I'm like,
how does he know this?
You see like,
so the attempt to help people see
experience patterns of meaning and
religious symbol is,
or how it connects to all levels of
reality.
That's what I've been trying to do for
years.
That's,
that's been my goal in life.
I would say in my carvings and my
articles and my talks,
no,
10,
there's only a handful of people that I
know that I can relate to at that level.
Okay.
And,
and it's not that people don't talk
about religious symbolism actually,
a lot of people do,
but usually when you hear people talk
about religious symbolism,
at some point you can kind of picture
them in like a tin foil hats and then,
you know,
they,
they soon extra terrestrials become part
of the,
of the discussion.
Um,
but not this guy,
he's just as clear as can be.
So when I get home,
so I reach out to him and I send them
just a little message.
Uh,
you know,
just thanking him and expressing my
surprise and linking into a few
articles.
I'd written a few talks I've given,
you know,
that was it.
I didn't expect,
I didn't really expect an answer,
but then the next morning I get,
I get a message thanking me for my
message and pointing me to a few lecture
that he had given more specifically on
religion.
I thought that's pretty cool.
Like,
that's,
that's nice.
This was random crew,
Becker's sending messages to him.
Um,
but then about about an hour and a half
later,
I get this call
and I can't do that.
I can't do the criminal voice.
So anyways,
my memories,
my memories of that moment are kind of
vague,
but I think I probably acted like a 14
year old meeting,
Kanye West or something.
And now his tone is one of surprise.
Maybe a bit of confusion.
And his basic question and,
and he's been asking me this question
ever since is how do you know this?
Because they listened to my talk and he
saw the relationship between what I was
saying and what he was saying and the
talk.
That's exactly,
I had been talking about how logos
organizes potential into experience been
it's a,
why am I,
why am I telling you this?
I mean,
first of all,
I'm telling you this as an excuse
because despite with father,
Ted said,
here's this carver who standing on one
theologian.
Then professors though the reason why
I'm here is because since then professor
Peterson and I have developed this,
this relationship.
Some of you might've seen the interviews
that we did together.
MMM.
But mostly I'm telling you this because
I know,
I know that it nears the story of so
many people that are probably here in
this room and,
and,
and a lot of the people that might hear
his,
uh,
on Youtube,
we're in the podcast.
I know that it years.
And I know because dozens of people have
told me of that experience,
you know,
I have this image,
I don't know if people have seen it,
of Joe Rogan hearing Dr. Peterson talk
for the first time and his jaw dropping,
you know,
and all of a sudden he sees religion in
a completely different way.
And I've even received dozens of message
from,
I would call them in process atheists
who say,
you know,
Mike questions.
And my thinking had been tilted slightly
in unexpected ways.
And that experience I think has been
strongest for Orthodox Christians like
myself.
In fact,
I stopped counting the number of
messages I received from priests asking
me soap.
It says,
Dr. Peterson Orthodox or what?
And to which I usually answer,
no,
he just likes dusty Fgli.
And there was even one clergy,
clergy men who who,
who answered to that said,
Oh yeah,
he's Orthodox.
He just doesn't know it yet.
With this correlation has been
persistent.
So what is this connection?
What made the connection between a
traditional Christian like myself and
Dr. Peterson?
So obvious,
so immediate,
and all of this I believes resolves
around the notion of logos.
Okay.
The language of logos is the underlying
language of Christianity.
Of course,
we know the,
the,
the first vision of logos in
Christianity comes from the gospel of
Saint John.
In the beginning was the logos.
The logos was with God and the logos was
God.
He was in the beginning with God and
through him all things were made without
him.
Nothing was made that has been made in
him was life and that life was the light
of all mankind.
The light shines in the darkness and the
darkness has not overcome it.
And this vision of logos would be
continued and developed in the life of
the church.
And especially in the seventh century.
There was a saint,
his name is Saint Maximus,
the confessor.
And he really brought this image of
logos I would say to it's most detailed
or most elaborate vision.
And he did so by taking uh,
the notion of logos that was in the new
testament and he,
he brought and united it with the best
of what the western tradition had
already offered,
who was able to prune,
let's say what had come from philosophy
and and join it with what the Christian
message was.
So it would attain some clarity and
maybe some detail.
And so saint maximus explains that all
things have a logos which are,
which is its reason for existence,
its purpose and its origin all at once
and even its end.
So it's all those things at once.
And on top of that,
each thing has a multitude of low g,
that's a word we would probably never
heard before.
The is the plural of logos.
And so the,
the,
the low being there,
like the different qualities of things.
So the blueness of the blue or the
slowness of the slow and all of these
logies are brought together.
They're woven together,
we could say to sustain the existence of
the world.
It's really a map of meaning to use
Jordan's words.
Now these logo,
he's essences let's say,
or things,
they don't exist independently.
In the same way that scientists,
they leave things exist out there.
Uh,
rather they exist as they come together,
as they're joined together in our
encounter with the world.
And a pattern we could say,
okay,
so we could say for example,
like had a sunset,
has a certain amount of low view,
maybe even an indefinite amount of
characteristics of a sunset.
But as they come together to be the
experience of this sunset,
that's how we experience reality.
That's how we come into contact with
reality.
So all these qualities,
it's a light color,
vertical,
horizontal,
and the things,
the,
the sun,
the sky,
the earth,
all of these things.
And I could go on,
there's an indefinite amount of them.
What's important and making that
experience real is how all those logos
are united.
So,
and in a way they're,
they're united within us.
And human beings for Saint Maximus are
seen as this laboratory where the whole
world finds its cohesion and he
expresses it in the sense that the human
being is a microcosm,
if you could say a condensation of the
cosmos,
the place where the cosmos comes
together to make sense
in a good way to see it is,
is that human beings actually
participate being in the image of God,
they participate in creation.
We see that in the book of Genesis,
the book of Genesis.
God tells Adam to name the animals.
And so by his logos participating in a
limited way,
in the same manner that the divine logos
was the source of everything.
And the human participation in this
process is not a relativistic thing.
Uh,
it's not an individual thing.
I mean though it is flexible.
It's nonetheless the most objective of
processes as father Ted mentioned.
And so we need to be cautious though
because Saint Maximus warns us that it's
not just a philosophy or it's not just a
technical description of the world.
MMM.
This is important because thinking that
religious stories are exactly the same
kind of encyclopedic knowledge of modern
science is the wrong way to go with
this.
These logos,
these truth of most things are,
or categories of our engagement with the
world.
So maybe today we might call them
phenomena,
fifth phenomenological categories.
Okay.
So the discovery of truth of logos,
it's a personal journey.
It's similar.
Tang is Lee or refinement of our
understanding of the world.
But at the same time he becomes a
refinement of our person.
So to discover the true nature of things
is to walk on a path of truth.
So food is a wonderful thing and it's
useful for life.
But gluttony leads to our destruction
well is useful to accomplish important
things,
but avarice Ross the soul.
So you see,
it's not just a description of the
world,
it's a path that we walk as we
discovered with world.
And so sin in this vision of the world,
that horrible world,
that horrible word that no one wants to
hear sin.
Okay?
Is it just the breaking of arbitrary
rules,
but it,
it's in the misuse of the world.
And that misuse of the world ends up
being an untruth,
ends up being a lie or,
or,
or something that's false.
Something that separates things from
each other.
It's found when things are not aligned
with their purposes.
So for example,
a person,
uh,
it's not only a tool for my own
gratification person is not just a tool
so that it can advance myself in the
world.
And if I treat a person exclusively like
that,
then I will inevitably sin against that
person.
I mean,
of course,
it doesn't mean that a person cannot act
as it's cool for my gratification.
If I go see the baker and I get bread
from him,
he's the method by which I get my bread.
But the baker is not just a baker.
He,
he is a full person just as myself.
So when we steal or we lie or we cheat
if he,
cause we're not considering that the
person facing us to be a full blown
person,
to be what they are according to their
logos,
where we see them only as limited things
only as tools.
So this is true of people of things and
of actions.
So I was thinking about,
I was trying to think about the best
example that I could think of to,
to show this in terms of action and,
and,
and uh,
I thought of giving the example of,
of sex.
So we did the metaphysics of peppa.
And so I think we can get away with the
metaphysics of sex,
I hope.
But it's a question that desperately
needs to be answered today in our topsy
turvy times,
let's say.
So what is the logos of sexuality?
Well,
it has many Loci,
many purposes.
It's for the propagation of the species.
I hope at least a few of you still think
that despite what many people would want
us to believe,
it's
creates families and communities.
It brings two people together and that
type of communion in an expression of
love and it brings pleasure
those.
So those will be,
would be some of the Lobi I'm sure we
could find more that some,
those are the,
some of the Loci that sex exists and
there could be more.
But yeah,
idea in division of logos is that all
those things need to be brought together
in a pattern of some sort for them to be
a path towards logos.
Okay,
so if we think of the different logo and
we bring them together,
trying to think of the word,
what does that word when we,
all those things are together,
I think we have a word with a sacrament
of the church.
I'll let you figure it out.
What it is.
When all those things come together,
and so each of the separate purposes of
sex that I mentioned,
they're not wrong,
they're fine,
but they do come alive when we bring
them together.
If we don't,
then each separate purpose appears as a
kind of false hood.
It appears as a kind of lacking.
That's not enough.
Let's say for a truly traditional or a
truly complete vision of sexuality,
it cannot end.
There has to move towards he infinite.
It has to move towards God.
And so the ultimate logos of sexuality
is to be an image of the mystical union
with God.
I mean it's to be an image of our union.
With that,
with what is beyond us.
I mean,
and that image of the Mystical Union of
God with the Soul,
with cross of Christ,
with his church,
the marriage of heaven and earth is a
completely traditional image we find in,
in the church.
Fathers are in our tradition.
Okay.
And so that,
that image of the ultimate union,
the highest union with the infinite,
okay,
then it comes back down into the
multiple lobe.
All those other reasons for sexuality
that I mentioned and it feels dumb.
It makes them participate in the
transcendent purpose and become the very
relationship that binds them together.
And everything in our life can follow
that process.
Work,
food,
sleep,
ut.
And to engage the world in that frame
is,
is to find light everywhere.
To see life everywhere the world is no
longer made of the dead,
lifeless,
dirt,
the dead,
lifeless material that you use to,
to make things with.
And as we become better as people,
more truthful,
more grateful,
more free as he come closer to one
another in love.
And,
and by the way,
that's what love is.
Love is the manner in which all
different things,
all different people,
all different intentions,
can join together and exist in communion
and can become one while at the same
time preserving the multiplicity.
So as we follow this path,
the hidden logo and creation,
they shine through the world.
And today we might say that they
re-enchantment the world and the world
appears bright and full and not the gray
and dead shadows we often live in.
So that would be,
I hope,
a summary,
let's say,
of that path of logos.
But I haven't really explained what the
source of my excitement was on that
Friday night yet.
What the source of the excitement was
that has caused all this flurry of
attention to Jordan.
And I can tell you I didn't thinking
about this now for months now.
I mean,
some of us have,
and Jordan has been thinking about this
for months now.
Okay.
And I,
I think by now we can say that it's
really not about gender pronouns.
It's not,
it's about something that is a lot
bigger than that.
And I think I can say confidently by now
that it's about logos.
Yeah,
entire project or postmodernism.
The last 30 40 years of higher culture
and higher education has been a
systematic assault on logos.
Okay.
To decenter logos to deconstruct
narratives and value hierarchies.
So we are less slipping and sliding
without purpose and direction.
And now we've reached the end of what
postmodernism has to offer.
You can actually say we've,
that we've come to a point where
postmodernism has one.
Basically the cultural debate and a
philosophy was decries the center and
certain certainty has pernicious Lee
become the very center and
unquestionable authority despises.
So everything is upside down.
Everything is inside out.
Everything is becoming its opposite and
all these inversions and chaos or not to
be taken lightly,
it has brought about a sterile age,
literally stare while as people are not
having enough children to to fill this
society.
I think I keep thinking that maybe
they're missing a bit of fall census.
Yeah.
But it's also stair island that it has
brought about this narcissistic and
fragmented culture.
You see,
they told us that the center cannot
hold.
Yeah.
And how things fall apart and now
everybody's decrying the end of truth.
All of a sudden,
right?
Everybody is saying that we're entering
an age of post truth fake news.
I mean my goodness.
Even use it as an argument against Dr.
Peterson,
the debate on gender pronouns.
It's the postmodernist that heralded the
end of proof 40 years ago and now
they're surprised to see the effect it
has.
How chaos does not discriminate.
How is turning against them?
Just as they turned it against their
ideological enemies,
he wanted to change the world to sin.
Now they're surprised to find he's
slipping between your fingers.
What is most surprising and what is most
shocking to them?
He's defined that now having reached the
end of their pursuit,
having thought they had won.
He see from within the decomposing
residues of western patriarchy,
he see that there is a seed that
sprouting that in the darkest place,
here's a flame that is lit,
logos or weekends.
The darkness has not overcome it.
Saint John promised this,
that
my postmodern friends,
if you had just paid attention to the
stories,
if you just paid attention to the
stories which are woven in the fabric of
our consciousness,
he's very stories you tried to
deconstruct,
you would have noticed that don always
comes.
That is seed is always planted.
The logos regains the center,
Christ raises from the dead.
Yeah,
and I think that's the excitement we're
feeling right now.
The find that small sparks that seed of
a meaningful pattern surprising us in a
collapsing world.
And it's not just a pattern of meaning,
but it's the beginning of a network of
people.
I mean just in the past two years,
there's a whole new strange group of
public figures that's arising from the
margins.
People who are at least trying to figure
it out,
who are at least trying to think clearly
and work out ideas and people who are as
different from each other.
As you can imagine spending across
gender,
race,
and cultures,
even religious and atheists alike trying
to figure it out.
And yet the media and the activists,
they scream hysterically,
bigot,
racist,
sexist,
Nazi,
all the usual litany of attacks and
they're losing their minds.
The sand is slipping out of their hand
and it's only two years ago we would
have probably collapse before this
attack.
But now you look around and we find that
there is a still silent center which to
sand in which to stand.
There is an eye and the overwhelming
hurricane
and we can finally say,
we will not accept your frame.
We will not accept your definitions.
They are weak by the very process you
use to deconstruct them,
to deconstruct the categories.
And we will speak for ourselves
what a relief.
But it is a dangerous time to time of
transition.
A time of chaos is,
it is a dangerous time.
First he,
the enemies of logos will ramp up their
hysteria and totalitarian tendencies as
logos awakens,
but it is also dangerous because that's
Christ himself told us the terrors grow
amongst the week.
The recentering of logos is the
reawakening of identities.
He can't avoid that.
And that's a frightening thing.
Cause if identity stops at the relative
low yogi without aiming,
without uniting itself to the highest of
high,
it can be murderous.
Okay.
And it has been increasingly murderous
just in the past century.
And it is in fact the very murderous and
genocidal tendency of identity,
which provoked the postmoderns to
deconstruct identity in the first place.
And there's a part where we can't blame
them for that.
I mean,
in the shadow of Auschwitz,
what else can you do?
So what
we'll strive from this new sprout hand
on us will depend on whole of us.
What will rise from this chaos you've
seen excite me?
Exciting,
but also frightening possibilities of
what that might look like.
I mean,
will it be race again so that we inch
towards genocide?
Would it only be nation?
So we're tempted to revisit the world
wars.
Well,
they'd only be gender lid only be class.
The schemes run out first.
My Saint Maximus,
the ultimate identity,
the place where all meaning finds its
resolution is the divine logos,
the source of everything.
That is our trajectory as we walk.
The path of logo says we are transformed
by truth.
The finality is to be united with God.
And I know that for some people just the
word God causes allergic reactions.
And I'm sure people listening to this
will be developing hives on their skin
as the cause they hear this.
Then maybe we can just think of it this
way.
For identity to be more than a weapon,
it must reach its highest point in
something that is beyond who ally.
And so finding,
seeing our highest identity in God is
finding unity with everything and the
source of everything.
And in terms of Christianity in
particular,
the identity was Christ is different
from other identities because it's the
identity with the cross and he needs to
identify with suffering.
I mean it's not the identity of a self
serving power with the identity of a
self emptying,
power of power,
bound in low at empties itself out of
love.
I mean it doesn't mean that we shouldn't
struggle.
Does it mean that we should just lay
down and give up?
Okay,
you should let our enemies destroy what
we value most and he cry.
Christ bought,
brought a whip into the temple after
all.
But what it really entailed would it w
what's important about it,
and this is something that is echoed
profoundly and with Dr. Peterson has
been telling us,
is that we must first walk on the path
that logos ourselves.
We must embrace our own suffering in
that truth.
You must take up our cross.
You must do so with a desire to first
get rid of the lies which to blind us.
Just straighten our own path and in
doing so well that is how we will change
the world.
Since Sarah Finn was sorrow is known to
have said save yourself and thousands
around you will be saved.
As we walk that path,
as
we strip away our own excesses rather
than look,
rather than looking at the imbalances of
others,
as we strip away our bad habits in our
narcissism,
rather than acting like victims,
the rule change
and we will start to see and to
experience logos to fully live within
the patterns of meeting that constitute
the world.
If you take that journey,
I guarantee that the universal patterns
of meaning will manifest themselves so
strongly in your life.
Yeah.
At first you'll use the word
synchronicity,
but soon you will have no other word to
use besides here.
And the postmodern chaos with vantage
has wax melts before the fire and logos,
very logos that rises from the grave
will fill your world and the world with
life and light.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
yeah,
so I'm going to start with a hypothesis.
No,
I spend a lot of time thinking about,
yeah,
religious symbolism in archetypes,
but there's,
there's,
there's a
problem with that and the problem is
it lacks concretization notes to think
about.
The ultimate ideal is as,
as only something that's symbolic.
It moves away from the real world.
And it's for partly for this reason
that
there's an insistence in Christianity
that the logo says two things at once.
It took me a long time to figure this
out and I was guided in my attempts to
understand it by Carl Young was truly
remarkable person and probably orthodox
in his fundamental conviction.
So I would say
he talked about the logo says the thing
that existed at the beginning of time.
This is a very particular way of looking
at things.
And so the idea is essentially that,
as Jonathan pointed out,
that there's something about
consciousness that calls forth being
from chaotic potential.
And you won't understand what this means
because when you look at the future,
or if you look at yourself,
you know that what you confront is a
field of potential.
And everyone tells you that.
They
tell you you're not living up to your
potential.
And potential is a very strange thing
because it doesn't.
You have to exist.
And so by the canons of the same modern
science,
it's not something that has any reality
whatsoever,
but everyone knows precisely what it
means.
And everything around it was full
potential because you can interact with
it and bring forth new things and you
know that.
And you can be called for your failure
to do it and you,
you,
you call,
you call out yourself for your failure
to do it because you wake up at three in
the morning and you,
and you torture yourself with your
inability to bring forth the potential
that's within you and it,
and it haunts your soul.
And it's hellish.
And the reason it's hellish is because
it is hellish.
And if you don't call forth the
potential that's within you and outside
of you,
then in the world does transform to hell
because that's its tendency anyways.
And we've had no shortage of evidence of
that in the last 100 years.
It's,
it's part of the Christian doctrine that
at the beginning of time,
the logos of Yahuah
operating on potential and brought forth
habitable,
the habitable world or,
and it was perfect in some strange
sense.
It was the paradise in which Adam and
Eve were placed in the paradise was a
walled garden,
a well watered place in the walled
garden is a place of order and chaos,
culture and nature.
And that's because people inhabit a
garden of culture,
nature,
that that's,
that's our environment.
And if those two properties are properly
balanced and inside that garden,
everyone can flourish.
And human beings are principal made in
the image of that logos.
And that's why we can speak things into
B.
And we do.
And when you speak truth,
then you speak paradise into being.
And when you speak falsely,
you speak heroin being,
and that's the truth.
And what that means is that with every
decision that you make,
you decide for yourself and for everyone
else,
whether you're going to tilt the world a
little bit more towards hell or a little
bit more towards heaven.
And that's the burden that you bear for
your existence and the choices that you
make as you pass through life.
And it's the fleeing from that.
That's at the bottom of the nihilism of
postmodernism and the escape into the
totalitarian certainties of idol
worship.
Okay?
And none of this is fictional because
we've seen the consequences.
Jonathan said quoting,
I don't remember the source that there
could be no poetry after,
but that's wrong.
But the poetry has to be about
Auschwitz.
Okay?
The lesson for Marsh,
which was never again and fair enough,
but you,
you can't
decide not to repeat something terrible
unless you understand it
and way you don't understand it.
Is that
the smallest things that each individual
culminate in a great sense of the state.
And so when you ask why terrible things
happened in the world,
the answer's quite simple.
The answer is it's because you're not
good enough
and it's because you don't tell the
truth.
And you know,
John,
if it said something I thought was very
interesting,
it's something I've thought about,
but I haven't talked to him about it at
all.
What happens as you move towards the
truth and the answer is everything comes
together.
It really,
really is.
The answer is everything comes together.
There's even a sexual element to that
because of course,
the highest element of sexual ecstasy is
to come together
and
around someone who's telling the truth.
Everything comes together and that's the
potential guests,
any of the world.
It's something that you can partake in.
It's the calls,
it's the call to the [inaudible]
greatest adventure that there is.
You can bring forth something akin to
paradise by speaking the truth and you
can start in your own life and you can
start it in the life of your own
families.
And these are people in principle that
you love and so why would you do
anything but speak the truth to them to
protect them from reality?
There's no protecting anyone from
reality.
Reality just is
you interact with it on your,
on its terms and you do that my face and
get forthright and you do that by not
shying away from the challenge.
I spent a lot of time trying to
understand the sermon on the mount.
It's a very strange document.
I'm going to tell you what I think it
means.
It means conceptualize the highest good
that you can
and so you might think that would be the
highest good for you and it would be the
highest good for the family around you
that you love.
And it would be the highest good that
family in the state and it would be the
highest good for the state.
In the world and that would be the
highest possible.
Good a bit that even though you don't
know how amy,
that make that what you want
and then tell the truth and it's an
adventure because you don't know what's
going to happen.
You have no idea.
Because if you treat things
instrumental,
you treat people instrumentally,
you use them as tools for your own
desires and not.
The problem with that is what do you
know about what you've designed?
Many things that you chased will turn
out to be empty.
Okay,
well what happens if you just tell the
truth?
Well,
the world will unfold around you in very
strange and mysterious ways and there
isn't anything gets more exciting to now
and it's perhaps something excited me
enough.
So that is suffering hits attendant on
being would redeem itself.
Why not adventure?
And that's the call.
That's the western call to the
individual is suffering of being can
redeem itself through truth.
And it's not,
it's,
it's not a rule.
It's not a proposition that you need to
adhere to like a good citizen.
It's,
it's the proper way of when did your way
through the terrible world without
making it worse than it already is,
and with the possibility perhaps of
making it better.
There's no more exciting possibility
than not and no higher moral demand.
And the thing is,
is everyone knows that you know,
when you lie according to your own
conception of the truth,
that there's something something
shameful and demeaning about that and
know that it hurts people and you think,
well,
why do you do it?
Despite all of that,
in part because it's easy and partly
being,
you do it because there's a crooked,
horrible,
hellish part of your soul that's more
than happy if part of what you do is
make everything worse to paid for the
sin of its existence.
And I would say we should stop doing
that and see what we can do it,
but got ourselves together as human
beings are remarkable creatures.
We put together an amazing civilization
working out at half time.
You know,
it's like 55% of humanity.
Okay?
On a good day is working to make things
better and 45% is working to make it
worse than you wonder what would happen
if we all just decided that we were
going to make things better.
As simple as that.
Start where you are,
make things around you better.
Where would we be?
What would the world turned into around
a civilization of people who were
genuinely trying to make things better?
I can tell you,
we better find out soon because if we
don't try collectively to make things
better given the current state of
affairs,
they are going to get a lot worse.
Okay.
I thought for a long time,
I wonder why people find themselves
adrift and meaninglessness and there's a
lot of answers to that.
There's the classical criticisms of
traditional faith and being put forth by
brilliant people like Friedrich
Nietzsche.
Okay.
There's the idea that there were a fairy
tales that people live by prior to the
modern age and revoke girl knows and
that's left this in a cosmo sticks
bereft of meaning and so it's a
consequence of the inevitable unfolding
of a kind of counting rationality.
And some of that's true,
but there's a lot of it isn't true
because I've also come to understand
that the reason that's many of us
proclaimed that life is meaningless this
because we actually would rather have it
be meaning less than to take
responsibility for it because you can
imagine this,
you can imagine this scenario.
Imagine you were offered a choice and
this is because you are offered this
choice.
If you'd say,
well,
absolutely nothing you do matters and
who the hell's going to know anyways?
Million years and so you can do whatever
you want moment to moment,
right?
That's the payoff for that perspective.
As you can do whatever you want moment
to moment and you will not be held
responsible by anyone including yourself
for pursuing your heading,
impulsive,
immoral,
foolish,
destructive genocidal tendencies or the
alternative is that you can assume that
everything you do is meaningful and
everything you do has an impact on the
way the world unfolds and take
responsibility for that and it's
something that you'll have your meaning.
All right?
That's for sure,
because you have an infinite amount of
responsibility for every mistake that
you make under those circumstances and
perhaps as a,
as a medic come in for that,
the knowledge that when you're on the
path properly that you're helping you
world unfold and the best direction that
it possibly could.
Well,
there isn't anything better than that.
If you want something to set against the
inevitable suffering of,
of life,
that's what you said against if eat
endless adventure of trying to make
things better in every possible way and
God only knows where we could get if we
did that around the perfect man,
everything comes together and I don't
believe that that's,
that's,
that's where the infinite logos that
express,
that stretches across time and space
comes together in a single individual.
That's the Christian story.
The reason for that is that every single
person is embedded in a specific time
and place.
That's you as an individual,
but at the same point,
you're also the involvement of this
thing that is active across forever to
call
chaos into habitable being.
You're both his divine,
eternal,
transcendent essence and the finite
shell that you inhabit.
It's like the genie,
right?
A genie is genius and the genius is
something that can grant three magical
wishes,
but how's to inhabit his tiny little
space?
It's the same idea.
Well,
you can act that out in your life and
you can transcend it,
and as you do that,
things come together around you and
everything becomes musical.
That's the right way to think about it.
And then everything becomes alive and
you shy away from that because you're
resentful about the fundamental
structure of being and you don't want
the responsibility and it's
no bloody wonder because the
responsibility is the responsibility for
everything.
You know?
That's why it's part of the Christian
story,
that Christ took the sins of the world
well themselves,
because that's what you have to do in
order to put yourself together.
It's your fault.
Everything isn't going right is because
you're not good enough.
Well,
who wants that?
Right?
Welcome.
The postmodernists has the lighten the
burden,
it consequences that nothing has any
meaning,
but that's a small price to pay to get
rid of that particular burden.
Well,
maybe not.
Maybe the meaning of life is to be found
in your voluntary willingness to take on
that burden and carry it.
Right.
Well,
that's the notion that's embedded in the
idea of the cross,
right?
To pick up a full conscious knowledge of
your own vulnerability,
your,
your subjugation to be trail,
your tear,
your,
your slavery at the hands of the state,
your insanity and your mortality and to
say,
I'll bear that voluntarily.
It's okay,
I can handle it.
It seems to me that we're at a kind of
crossroads.
I don't know exactly why you always meet
the Devil at the crossroads,
by the way.
And the reason for that is because every
crossroads is a choice,
right?
And it's always a choice between good
and evil.
We're at a crossroads and I don't know
why.
I guess it's because of the terrible
20th centuries and it's energy and now
we have something new.
In the aftermath of that,
it's time for everyone to pick up the
chaotic pieces and carry them
voluntarily and to make their way
through the world and to try to speak
their truth and to see what happens.
It will
eel yourself,
well,
heal your body,
heal your soul,
heal your family.
It'll heal the nation.
That's what truth now is and how could
it be any other way?
The reality is the truth and how are you
going to adapt to it without using the
truth.
While the problem,
his reality is the terrible truth and
it's certainly possible that a terrible
truth is its own medicine.
With regards to my connections
orthodoxy,
I have kind of a funny story to tell
about that.
Oh,
15 years ago,
a student of mine
who,
who I've maintained the relationship
with since I taught at Harvard.
MMM.
I'd helped him through a difficult
period.
He,
his family had been at the center of a
real storm of publicity like this,
a front page story for a number of
months.
Recently,
he
returned the favor with me,
but he proposed at one point that I fly
down to Los Angeles and act as the
officiant at his marriage.
And I thought,
that's interesting.
I never expected that to happen.
And so I thought,
well,
if I'm going to do that,
I better get ordained because that's
obviously the logical thing to do.
And I thought,
well,
how do you get ordained on short notice?
And obviously the answer to that and see
you go online.
So,
so I went online and I,
I signed up,
I could name my church.
So I did,
I have this church,
I'm the only member.
Yeah,
it's called the,
it's called the Church of the spirit of
St your chem of florists,
which you know,
isn't necessarily the name that you
would expect.
Um,
I like to say Yo Kim,
from what I knew of him,
because he had this idea that there were
three,
he paused.
There would be three parts of Western
civilization and one would be the epoch
of the father.
And that's what was like the Old
Testament and Old Testament reality that
has to do with following rules.
And then there was the park of the sun.
And that was of course the equal
Christian,
he parking for the last 2000 years.
And he believed that what would come
after that would be the power of the
Holy Ghost.
And the Holy Ghost is this weird
spirit thing
hypothetic Christ's left behind in habit
people and guide them on their path.
And it seems to me that that's very much
in keeping with the Orthodox idea that
the proper,
um,
moral pathway for each individual to
take is to attempt to bear the burden of
the perfect individual,
right to become Christ,
so to speak,
in an attempt to transcend more calorie
infinitude into and to unite with God.
And I thought,
well,
that was kind of a cool idea.
So I thought,
well,
I might as well have that as a church.
And then I thought,
who should I be in this church?
And I thought,
well,
poke was probably a little bit on the
narcissistic side,
let's say.
So I thought I'll be nips or Paula.
Yeah.
Because I thought that was kind of
archaic and House and sort of out of the
way enough so that it was a good joke.
So I'm my own metropolitan,
my own church.
It only has one rule.
And so you can show you it if you want.
Um,
the rule is that if you're a member of
my church,
you can't follow stupid rules.
Yeah.
So that's a good rule because it's
actually,
it's an anti rule,
rule lay,
which is really funny as far as I'm
concerned.
Anyways,
I went down to La and I did marry these
two and you're still married and so
that's good.
Yeah.
So I know that's a good family,
but it's been a long day.
Um,
I talked to Sam Harris today.
Again,
for those of you who it went great.
It went great.
Anyway,
so look,
the idea is pretty straightforward,
you know,
as far as I can tell through this
tremendous idea that's at the bottom of
western culture that's taken the human
race millennia and perhaps an endless
amount of time before then,
an eternal amount of time before then to
formulate.
The idea is that our consciousness,
and that's the center of us,
the soul,
whatever that happens to be,
partakes in the process by which
creation comes into va.
And we do that through the logos,
which is our capacity to think and to
other words and to engage in dialogue.
But more importantly to do that
truthfully and to the degree that we're
able to do that truthfully,
we bring paradise into being rather than
hell.
And it seems to me that that's as close
to objective reality,
although it's not precisely objective,
it's more than objective reality to kind
of Metta reality.
It's,
it's the most profound truth that you'll
ever encounter.
And the thing that's cool about it is
you can even,
you can put it to the test if you want,
you know,
you start deciding that you're not going
to lie because how the hell are you
going to tell the truth?
What do you know?
You don't know what the truth is,
but you certainly know when you're lying
and you know how to stop doing that.
So I would say,
well just try,
stop lying and see what happens.
Try it for like a year.
You don't get to lie about anything
anymore.
And that also means you can't do things
that you would be afraid to talk about
because you know if you're going to tell
the truth,
you have to tell the truth about what
you did.
And if you do reprehensible things,
then you can't just run around telling
everybody about them.
So it also means that you have,
if not act in a way that you wouldn't
speak truthfully about and try it.
You'll find out first of all,
that you're so full of lies and deceit
that you just bloody wall can't believe
it.
When I started doing this 30 years ago,
it really just about drove me crazy
because I divided into two people in
some sense and one person,
one person was talking and the other
person was watching,
the person that was talking in the
talking person was a puppet and the
watching person was the right person.
And every time the talking person said
something to watching,
first person could go eop elite that
that isn't true,
that isn't here idea.
And I thought,
wow,
that's really not good because it looks
like 95% of what I'm saying isn't mine.
Or I'm saying it for show or I'm saying
it can be dominant primate or unsaying
it so that I can be,
you know,
so that I can use my language
instrumentally and get what I want or,
or you know,
I swiped it from the book and I really
don't deserve it.
But I'm saying it like it was horrible.
It was 95% seriously.
And so then I learned at least in part
to only say things that made me feel
like I was together.
And that's a part of that coming
together.
You can feel that physically,
you know,
if you,
if you say something deceitful,
you shrink and you cower from it,
it makes you embarrassed and it makes
you weak.
You can feel the weakness.
So like,
well stop saying things that make you
weak.
If you don't want to be me,
then if you want to be strong,
stop saying things that make you feel
weak.
Try it.
See what happens.
You can test this out and here are
things will be way different for you in
five years.
You won't even be the same person and
God only knows what will happen in the
decades.
So it's really worth it.
We started,
you don't have an embedded to do anyways
because here you are,
you know,
suffering stupidly away,
you might as well do something useful
with your time while you're waiting to
die.
So,
and there isn't anything
I think more interesting to do than
that.
It's so cool because don't,
I mean it's part of what I decided to do
last September when I made these,
you know,
crazy videos,
which really have more of a necessity
and I certainly thought they would.
I thought,
well,
I've got some things to say and why
don't I say them and see what happens.
That's sort of,
that's an excellent way to live.
Why don't I say the things that I think
and see what happens.
Well,
this is one of the things that's
happened.
So that's kind of cool.
I mean,
how long likely is this?
It's completely absurd and ridiculous.
Here.
I'm with Jonathan,
this crazy French Canadian carver and
these two guys in dresses here on you.
Exactly.
That's exactly what you'd expect given
what I've been talking about recently
because it's very unlikely.
And all of this is being very unlikely
and life is very unlikely.
And you know,
maybe it could be absolutely
magnificent,
wonderful.
We could make everything into a holy
temple in which we did live forever,
peacefully only searching for more
remarkable and spectacular things to do
next.
And that's what people do with parents.
They sit around dreaming about how the
paradise they already had could give
rise to a paradise that's yet greater
than the one that's there.
And with the collective imagination that
we pursued,
that could be a never ending thing.
And we could bring it into being.
And that's what we should do.
Because the alternative is to let
everything degenerate into chaos and
hale.
And how about we don't do that?
Well,
that's good enough.
[inaudible]
MMM.
Thank you.
To Metropolitan Jordan at Toronto.
Um,
I just wanted to quickly say,
uh,
following other Jeffrey's talk,
we will have the question and answer
period.
So,
uh,
five minutes from now,
we'll have people walking by the isles
taking your um,
okay.
Question sheets as well as
on the balcony.
So,
um,
and uh,
after Father Jeffrey,
his uncle will have the question and
answer period and if you have more
questions after that we'll collect those
as well just
and if you're on the balcony,
just give them to Aden.
Thank you very much.
And the different,
good evening.
Well,
the Ted and I have had a,
an a running debates over the last few
weeks as to what would be worse going
first or going laughs,
how do I follow that?
The second century church did something
rather strange and quite astonishing
stories about Jesus,
which had been circulating orally for
some generations,
began to be written down in the second
half of the first century who are
numerous versions in circulation,
which came over time to be associated
with the traditions of one or another.
Epistolic witness to the risen Lord
Jesus.
And at a certain point,
a choice had to be made.
The church could have come up with a
definitive accounts,
the single canonical version.
And that approach was,
was certainly a temptation.
One of the first to do this was a
dualistic heretic called Marcy.
He settled on one Gospel,
the gospel of Luke as it happens.
You liked that,
huh?
Which he redacted.
However,
the suit,
his vision,
incidentally,
he also rejected the entire Old
Testament and the process teaching that
matter was evil and therefore the
creator God of the Old Testament was
responsible for it.
But the point here is that he wanted a
single goal,
spoke to reflect Jesus,
who he saw as offering salvation from
this material world that was a harrison.
This thing,
this idea of a single gospel continue to
be a temptation even for those within
the canonical church in the middle of
the second century and otherwise quite
orthodox believer rotation apparently
scandalized by the plurality of the
gospels,
created his famous via Tesoro.
In this,
he wove the gospel accounts into one
seamless consistent narrative and it had
some traction.
In fact for some centuries,
particularly among the Syria a
tradition.
This was the main gospel use,
but the church rejected both of these
attempts and from the beginning of the
process of the canonization of the New
Testament,
it accepted that there should be
different gospels leading the charge was
the second century bishop of Neil
[inaudible] who insisted or what he
called the oven Galyon Techco Morpho the
four fold gospel already in his days
day.
Those were the four gospels we have in
our new test and today
this is important,
fully aware of the significant
differences in the accounts,
not only different emphases and
theological visions,
the contradictions the church chose to
canonize diversity.
It shows to retain for separate and
distinctive literary compositions
witnessing to the life,
death and resurrection of Jesus.
This is interesting for all kinds of
reasons and of course it points to the
experience of Jesus being more profound
than any one account with capture but
not least.
And for our purposes and theme tonight,
it also says something about the meaning
of what it is to be human.
As a new testament scholar,
Luke Timothy Johnson drives the
diversity of the Gospel.
Accounts signifies the infinite
recommended replicability of the story
of Jesus in the lives of human beings.
Okay?
The story of Jesus is not simply a pass.
The church declares it continues as the
spirit of Jesus transforms the lives of
human beings according to the mind of
Christ,
but in what sense can the story of Jesus
be replicated?
Surely not in the specifics of his
ministry,
which are irretrievably in the past.
It's not about being a celibate,
bearded Jewish male growing up in
gallery in the first century Palestine
technology.
Someone who works with his hands like
it's awesome.
Father.
Such historical elements are not
repeatable.
Neither are they important to the piece,
rather the plurality of the gospels in
their variety of and contradictory
historical details.
Oh,
it's beyond all this to a deeper
significance.
That is to the meaning of the story of
Jesus contained in these.
It's not the facts of Jesus's life that
matter and find new expression in the
lives of others,
but rather a pattern of his existence.
Jesus' existence as one of radical
obedience towards God and selfless
service towards others forms a pattern
for all humanity that can be written in
the heart by the Holy Spirit.
It's this pattern that Paul designates
as the normals.
History often translated the law of
Christ,
but it's better understood perhaps as
the pattern of Christ,
the pattern of the Messiah.
As an aside,
his concept of the pattern of Christ
etched into the multiform narratives
that witness to the life,
death and resurrection of Jesus.
It was also the reason for the limits
that were placed on what could be
considered gospel.
You see,
a diversity was not just allowed but a
requirement to express the fullness of
truth.
It was nevertheless a bridge too far and
the rejection of the so-called gnostic
gospels with which I'm sure many of you
are familiar,
was precisely that.
They were not narratives but often just
collections of safe and that makes
sense.
The gnostics were not interested in the
material world,
and to have a story requires
materiality.
There sacred texts as much as they
purported to be about Jesus lacks
precisely the narrative element of the
passion of Christ.
Now,
time does not suffice for us to explore
together this evening.
How across all the various writings of
the New Testament,
this underlying pattern of price,
the or maybe each outline,
the very brief list of sketches in the
four gospels and the letters of Paul and
the other early apostles.
Behind all the collected facts,
there's a deep consistency and the
earliest Christian literature concerning
a focus not on wondrous deeds or even
wise words or on the character of Jesus
as Messiah on the meaning of his life
and death.
They all reveal the same pattern of
radical obedience to God and selfless
love towards other people.
They reveal a journey that plunges to
the depths of alienation in solidarity
with all and then rises in
glorification,
having not nearly overcome suffering,
sin and death,
but empty of their power.
They reveal a pattern of joyful
sacrifice,
voluntary death,
and glorious resurrection.
And they also all agree on this,
that discipleship is the follow the same
messianic pattern.
They don't emphasize that followers of
Jesus performs certain deeds or learn
certain doctrines.
They insist rather on living according
to the same pattern of life and death
shown by Jesus.
To be a Christian therefore is not about
dogma.
We've been morality,
although there are dogmatic and ethical
implications.
It's not about all that religious
baggage.
We so often associated with it.
It is to live.
It is for each of us to enact in our
unique human existence.
The numinous is to a pattern.
Now,
there are numerous ways we can describe
this pattern of prize.
For instance,
the eastern fathers principal mode of
exegesis of understanding scripture is
tychology,
so we can add to pattern the word
pattern.
Another word,
depots or type.
A type is a person and object or an
event that is connected across space,
time to others.
Without losing its own historical
reality and identity,
it shares in a greater reality of
meaning,
that greater reality,
which it points a greater reality called
the anteater.
This is how the apostles and the church
fathers read the entire Old Testament.
For example,
Adam Saint Paul says,
is a t posts a type of Christ,
the first created man pointing forward
to the recreation of the human rights
race in price Jesus.
The exodus narrative as an event is a
type of a true Passover or Pascal
Christ,
deliverance of old people from suffering
and death in anyone is familiar with the
writings of the church.
Fathers are of the liturgy of the
Orthodox church who know how abundant
types are within them.
But this is the key.
Topology is not just a way of reading
and understanding history in seeing how
people and Events Point towards Christ.
Topology is for eastern fathers the
fundamental structure of reality of a
world that is symbolic of an,
uh,
an epiphany or theophany of God and of
our own apprehension of this reality,
our own finding of meaning within it.
So it's not just figures from scriptural
history that are types,
we too are cold to typify Christ,
to be symbols of Christ.
Participants in his archetypal journey
and life is dissent in self offering.
And he's a scent you Lord.
If we are to be truly human,
we must follow what distinguished
scholar of this university.
Northrop Frye calls the u shaped story.
That is the foundation,
not only a biblical narrative and the
Christ story,
but a story after story,
Myth after myth in Christ,
the archetype of archetypes we have in
the words of Cs Lewis myth become fact.
As we've already heard this evening in
the gospel of Saint John,
of course,
this pattern is above all called logos.
It's not an abstract pattern,
but it's a direct and in these latter
days in the fullness of time had direct
incarnate expression of God himself.
The logos is the principle of order and
creation as we've heard.
It's through the logos that God speaks
and all things are made.
It is logos,
God's verb,
perhaps better than word verb in whose
image we are creators whose likeness we
are called to attain.
And the lesson here is simply this that
are properly ordered.
Human life is one lived in accordance
with the locals.
The concept of logos has a long and
venerable history and it did even before
the Greek translators of the Old
Testament and the new testament writers
appropriated it and one of the first
hour,
the first of the Greek philosophers to
speak of logos was the pre socratic
hereclitis and he said this to low bu
the end.
Those seniors who seen equally,
although logos is common to all all have
the locals,
the many live as if they had a wisdom of
their own.
In other words,
lobos may govern the University of Macro
Cosmos and our own inner world,
the Amico Osmoles,
but most people don't choose a properly
ordered life,
a life aligned with the compass built
into the fabric of the world built into
their own hearts and minds.
We've heard already,
we are now in the season of Great Lens.
The great 40 days is at school and this
has significances.
It's a season of course,
have a set of labor of renewal.
If faith redoubling of our commitment to
prayer and the service of others.
It's also the season and preparing
catechumens apap
above over.
It's the season where we're called to
come to our sense and to awake to the
fundamental meaning,
shape and pattern of our lives.
We realize our alienation.
We repent with Tanya,
we embark on our journey of return,
a journey which involves self sacrifice,
a journey which necessarily passes
through our own voluntary death and
resurrection.
Lent is in essence the totality of our
life,
but it requires the remembrance of
death.
It was a famous practice in ancient Rome
as a general came back victorious from a
battle and during his triumphant parade
receive compliments and honors from the
crowd of citizens.
He ran the risk of falling victim to his
own pride and delusions of grand jury.
And to avoid that,
a slave would be placed just behind him,
whispering into his ear saying,
hey,
speech a post post-stay onm team
momentum.
We'll look after you to the time of your
death and remember,
you're only a man thereafter.
It was enshrined and picked up in
Christian tradition as Memento Mori.
Remember that you will die,
but better yet remember to
remember to write and think we need that
remembers,
but maybe because eventually all of us
will probably improve equal to the task
but remember to die because remember to
find and follow the logos,
the pattern of our true life which
passes through death to resurrection,
very frequent theme and patristic
tradition.
Saint Gregory,
the theologian often repeats the saying
of Plato which suggests that the present
life or to be a meditation on death and
he advised his friend for luxurious to
live instead of the present the future
and make this life a meditation and
practice of death and could go on from
the church fathers,
the focus on death is front and center
remembrance of our journey that passes
from death to life.
This is also the connection of lent with
a preparation for baptism.
Baptism in its deepest in primary sense
signifies death and burial and
resurrection with Christ.
This is very clear in Romans chapter six
the epistle which we read on the eve of
Easter,
Costco,
we have been baptized into Christ death.
We have been buried with him by baptism
into death.
We have been united to Christ in a death
like his and united to him and as a
resurrection like his.
So baptism means death and resurrection.
Saint Gregory of Nissa says the is both
to and mother
you Orthodox theologian Paul Ever hemos
writes about this is the extended
quotation if you're there with me and
just him,
he says,
means sharing mystically in Christ's
death and his burial,
but also in what happened between his
burial and his resurrection,
his descent.
He's a hell.
What is the meaning of the incarnation?
God becoming truly human in Christ
identifies himself with all human
anguish,
alienation,
and despair in the garden of get 70 he
says,
my soul is exceedingly sorrow.
Even unto death.
You shares in the fullness of human
pain.
He enters into the fullness not only of
human life,
but if human death,
and we are to understand Christ descent
into hell as being the full expression
of God's solidarity with our human
alienation.
Christ descends into the hell of human
suffering.
And if human loneliness,
loneliness,
a human despair,
surely he has borne our griefs.
And carried our sorrows as we read in
the book of Isaiah and we may add that
Christ has worn all,
all our silos.
There was a total identification here
and unreserved solidarity of priced our
God in our human fallenness.
He who is sinless yet became sin for us.
He became one with us in our foreman's
age as the Paul says,
and that is part of the meaning of this
descent into hell.
All things are full of uh,
even hell though I go down to hell,
thou art there also maybe you so much,
38 so when we are baptized,
he love continues.
We just send it priced into hell.
We also commit ourselves in solidarity
with price to the scene.
Total unreserved identification with
those who suffer.
Each of the baptize becomes by virtue of
his descent into hell with Christ,
a man or a woman for others.
Each of us is called to bear the griefs
of others is it carry their sorrow.
He a Christian ne to be a human requires
us to journey to hell.
It is in use terms to journey to hell
and become hell oneself.
That's how we can make sense of the
words of a great elder of the 20th
century seems sort of Rooney who went as
a young man,
asked him,
how will we be saved?
Answered he your mind in Hell and just
bearing on
why can't,
why this archetyping descent before
ascending?
Why The you pattern of Christ that we
must follow,
um,
as in how much her of physics,
if you will indulge me.
Let me offer a metaphor from physics.
And I'm this from a scholar of Orthodox
Christian liturgy.
David bigger book archimedes was a Greek
physicist who was fascinated by the
mechanic and mathematics.
The lever,
and you may remember from your science
classes and simple machines that are
lever is used to exert a large force
over a small distance.
I exerting a small force over a greater
distance at the other end or a child and
that's lift with one hand and a man
standing on the shore.
And if the child presses down on the
long,
archimedes was so fascinated by the
leavers potential.
Then one day he famously swing,
give me a lever and a place to stand.
Am I?
Shall move.
Okay.
And he realized three things in order to
move here,
a long enough lever,
a correctly placed fulcrum points and a
place to stay.
But that of course was the problem when
it comes to moving the earth.
How could he apply leverage to the world
when he himself was standing on the
world?
How could he step off the thing he lives
on in order to move it?
He has no footing.
So in philosophy,
the riddle becomes known as searching
for the archimedean point.
That is an objective standpoint.
Removed from the object of study is
hypothetical point of perspective is
thought to be far enough removed from
something in order to afford an
outsider's view of it.
How can we remove ourselves to a point
of site oh seven this is our human
condition.
A gustin defines sin as Info vacs was
insane.
Being curved in upon oneself.
I like oriented inwardly towards self
rather than outward towards scarf and
others are egocentrism exert so strong
gravitational pull that it bends the
light of glory back on ourselves.
That light that should be glorifying
God.
How can we move ourselves off center
movie or the center of our universe?
We have no leverage overseeing.
We have new standpoint outside our
vanity and pride.
We have no rock on which to stand that
is beyond ourselves.
Interests,
whoever desires to get outside himself,
eat some sort of our Canadian points,
the owns and stuff,
our self offering and are just sent to
hell is precisely this archimedean
point.
If we are to lift the war,
if we are to transform the world into a
true symbol and epiphany of God's own
life and when he was first,
he said,
we cannot lift up the world in
sacrificial trace along as we placed in
our footing on the world alone,
it's like trying to lift the carpeting.
Why we stand on it.
Archimedes,
his problem was applying leverage to a
world that he could not step off of in
order to move it.
Well,
we can.
I dying with Christ.
We freed from the roads.
We leave the world's for the sake of the
world.
We die so that we in the world with us,
they live.
This is not nearly our spiritual life,
our religious vocation,
some crazy notion dreamed up by men with
black dresses
are true life.
It is our proper life.
It is our life ordered according to the
logos and it is a journey we must
undertake.
We undertake not on our own,
the only in Christ or Christ and Christ
alone is the one who took that journey
so that we could be reconciled to God.
In closing,
I would like to turn to one of the
greatest in my own estimation,
poets of the past century,
one who saw deeply into these realities
of locals and journey through death and
resurrection.
He his poem,
the wasteland,
Tsl,
he depicts a bleak world.
It's a world in which we fail to take up
our journey,
where we stay put amidst the
civilization that's been reduced to a
wasteland that has lost its fertility
and its ability to bring forth life.
The world is filled.
He says with a heat of broken images and
the dead tree gives no shelter.
There is no easy fix and certainly
nothing in that civilization or society
could offer.
There no levels.
It's such a world.
Sound familiar to us today.
We need to look at Elliot spinal work,
the four quartets for hope of renewal
and spiritual replenishing,
telling me above this series of four
posts.
The last thing he wrote,
he's inscribed those words of hereclitis
that I mentioned before.
Although logos is common and many live
as if they had wisdom of their own
elliot headset.
The solution to our wasteland is not
your new civilization per se on its own
terms,
but a journey undertaken in the pattern
of the logos.
He says this,
it's a symbol perfected.
Yeah,
all shall be well and all manner of
things shall be well by the purification
of the motive in the ground of RBC CIBC,
he goes on to evoke an image,
this beautiful image of the fire of the
Holy Spirit,
purifying as a de horrifying the world
is.
It just says as a dog and he ends with
this on a whole.
For them in which descends to death is
the source of life and meaning and
transformation.
We die with the dying.
See,
they depart and we go with them.
We are born with the Dead Sea,
they return and bring us with them.
The moment of the rose and the moment of
the huge tree equals your Asian people
without history is not redeemed from
time for history is a pattern of
timeless moments.
So while the light fails on a winter's
afternoon in a secluded chapel,
history is now and be the drawing of
this love and the voice of this call,
we shall not cease from exploration.
And the end of all our exploring will be
to arrive where we started
and know the place for the first time
through the unknown remembered gates.
When the last of the earth left to
discover is that which was the beginning
at the source of the longest river,
the voice of the hidden waterfall and
the children and the apple tree.
No,
no,
because not looked for but her half.
It's still miss between two waves of the
sea
here.
Always condition of complete simplicity,
costing not less and everything and all
shall be well and all manner of things
shall be well when the tongues of flame
or enfolded into the crown at and off
the fire.
And the fire and rose
[inaudible] [inaudible]
what an amazing engine to artists
commissions.
And I just get another round of applause
for all our patterns.
[inaudible]
so it's eight 47 right now,
but just letting you guys know,
even though a,
the event says that the event ends at
9:00 PM we do have the room til 10,
so we have plenty of time for questions.
Um,
so with that said,
if you guys have anymore questions that
develop along the way,
you can just write them down and asked
them up.
And I always try to get to as many as
possible and if I'd ask the questions
that kind of answer as many other
questions as possible.
So with that said,
and this question does not adjust to any
analysts in particular by whichever of
you feels like you would like to answer
this question.
Um,
the do.
So a statue in Rome depicts the
suffering of the Trojan priest Lado Con,
I'm pronouncing that correctly.
And his sons,
unlike the noble suffering of Christ on
sufferer,
lot of sufferings science seems neither
awarded nor justified.
Do these two
differing visions of suffering form part
of the divide between postmodernists and
their opponents and do the postmodernist
justify their nihilism and or believe in
other ideologies by pointing to the
pointless suffering a lot of time and
others like him.
You don't have a harder question.
He'll be answering this
like to
anyone.
It's about sculpture.
Well meaning,
well,
indeck is just meaningless suffering.
Is that the core of the postmodern
understanding goats,
the problems in the world?
I don't know if it's at the core,
precisely
of the postmodernists view.
I think it's at the core of
the problem that every human being has
with manifesting sufficient faith to
engage fully in life.
We look at our lives and the lives of
others and we see that the one certainty
is suffering and loss and we're at least
in principle,
the only creatures that are aware of
that.
That's really the story in genesis of
Adam and eve.
Right?
Because Adam and eve wake up and become
aware of their own nakedness there
finitude your mortality and that throws
them out of the paradise of being and
that's,
that's precisely right.
That's the situation we all find
ourselves in.
The fundamental question is all that
without ultimate meaning.
And it's a very profound question.
Yeah.
The answer seems to be something like
it's without meaning unless you take it
on voluntarily.
And I don't,
I certainly don't understand the full
implications of that answer,
although I know that in so far as you
can test that as a theory in your own
life,
it seems extraordinarily robust.
Yeah.
To the degree that it's a postmodern
issue,
I think that the postmodernists
postmodernists feed us very thin rule
because they offer nothing in the face
of that suffering except the collapse of
everything into the sound that Jonathan
spoke up.
That's the best I can do with that.
Great.
To Mr Patio,
how do your icons and icons and general
function on their day to day search for
the logos?
MMM,
I think,
I think they,
there's many ways in which they
function.
Okay.
Uh,
one of the things that I did I talked
about is the idea that the,
the path of logos is a path of coming
together.
And one of the things that icons provide
is that image of coming together.
So when you engage with an icon,
especially in a church where there are
many icons and many saints,
then you get that sense of uh,
your path being one in which you are in
communion with others.
And so for Orthodox Christian,
for example,
when we prayed before icons,
we,
we pray before them because through the,
through those images,
we,
um,
we can,
how can I say this in a,
in a way that can,
everybody can understand.
So the image becomes a vehicle for the
presence of that person into our prayer
lives.
And there's this relationship which is,
which is set up.
And so that's,
that is how we live with icons and icons
become a,
a,
a vehicle for that,
for that path towards,
towards unity.
So I hope that helps.
That's on,
let's say,
on a experiential,
a sense,
I think in a technical sense,
in terms of the making of icons for
myself,
uh,
for me that's what they have done
exactly is that my struggle in life
before I became orthodox was how to fit
art that I loved into my life.
How to make that fit and how for it to
all come together.
And in discovering the language of
traditional Christian art,
I found how here's this art,
which is both grounded in absolute
practical use in the lives of people.
It's,
it's used in people's devotions.
It's using the church to teach and to
participate in the liturgy.
Uh,
and at the same time I can participate
in that by making them,
uniting me with,
with the tradition of all the fathers
before me uniting you with the church.
And at the same time,
these images,
what they're talking about and what
they're revealing is that ultimate
reality,
that reality that is beyond all
realities.
And so being able for myself,
I feel great blessing to have the chance
and have the,
uh,
the blessing of the church to be able
to,
to do that for a living.
It's amazing every day I get to
participate in that process.
And so,
uh,
that's my other answer to that question.
Okay.
Just quickly to add to that point,
icons in the Orthodox church or not
merely seen,
but they teach us to see,
um,
you will have noted that there is a,
they're not just an aesthetically
beautiful medium.
They have a kind of stylization even,
uh,
even though the mini styles of
iconography,
they share a characteristic and that
there is something about them that
forces the viewer to reflect and to come
to a new way of seeing.
So icons are not merely symbols as such,
but they teach us to understand all of
reality in that symbolic sense that I
spoke of earlier,
that everything ultimately isn't
referencing itself.
That's the problem that we are in.
That things have become self
referential,
that everything in the world is an icon,
is a symbol of God.
And it's referring to something much
more than what it is beyond itself
without losing its identity.
So icons teach us that vision not just
depicted.
That makes sense to teach us a way of
seeing.
Just a quick reminder that I'm following
up on a professional.
Peterson said,
um,
there's the average person wants to take
the easy route,
right?
So when you take a look at icons and
Orthodox church,
there's a lot of people who've never
seen them before.
They say,
well,
those are weird.
They,
they,
they're not realistic.
They're very strange looking.
Uh,
they're done on purpose because the icon
involves you.
Okay?
It forces engagement with the local,
well,
we've been speaking about tonight
because from the colors that are used
to,
you know,
the subtle code that exists within
iconography that,
okay,
if you haven't studied it,
you wouldn't know.
But if for the people who read up on it
and begin to engage,
um,
it forces you to read the icon and to
get deeper and deeper into what it's
trying to tell you.
Even the prospective.
And Jonathan knows us very well in most
icons,
not all,
but in most Byzantine icons,
the perspective is even reversed and if
those of you are taking basic art,
you know vanishing point is far away,
right?
Things get further away when you get,
when you get,
when you look,
when you look into the distance and
things get bigger when they get closer
to you.
But if you look at the geometry of an
icon,
a lot of times you'll see that it's
reversed.
Wait,
why?
Because the vanishing point is actually
pointing towards you,
towards the viewer,
which means that when you look at it,
you become part of it and the
orientation of the icon is actually
looking at you.
You're not just looking at the icon.
The icon is looking at you and that
forces a type of involvement and it's
hard work because if the learn how to
read it,
you can't just look at it and I don't
want to contrast it as with with,
for example,
renaissance painting as as better or
worse.
It's just two different things.
But when you look at renaissance
painting,
it's realism.
It's just,
it's there to depict what exists as it
is.
And there's not a lot of work there.
There's a lot of work from us from a
technical point of view.
But to look at it,
you know,
there's,
it is what it is.
It stops there.
Whereas the icon,
as Jonathan was saying,
it kind of reveals another world,
the world that could be the world that
we would want to be.
Um,
and,
and that is a beautiful thing because
it's a constant engagement with,
with um,
with our hope in the eternal.
Thank you.
This question is for Jordan Peterson.
Can you comment on the cyclical or non
cyclical pattern of history and if our
society is doomed to decay or can it be
renewed culturally?
Oh,
in order of society,
state and laws.
Okay.
Well,
I would say it's cyclical at every
moment.
In some sense it's nested patterns of
cyclicality and I think you can hear
that best in the best representation
I've ever seen of that is inbox
Brandenburg concertos.
Here.
They're really worth a listen.
Um,
the new videos I'm going to release that
I'm doing with interviews use Bach's
third Brandenburg Concerto,
which is an absolutely phenomenal piece
of music because it its cycles and
climbs continually and stays in the same
place.
I have no idea how he managed it.
It's,
it's absolutely overwhelming and that's
what history is like.
The apocalypse is always on us,
right?
I mean,
you all confront an apocalyptic
yesterday because you're all going to
die and everything comes to an end and
everything is continually regenerate it.
And so that cyclicality is built into
every moment.
That's the u shaped journey that
northrop Frye talked about too,
which is order a descent into chaos and
the reestablishment of order and
everyone knows what that means in their
own life.
You're somewhere stable where you
understand everything and things are
going well for you and then the rug is
pulled out from underneath your feet and
you don't know where you are or you fall
into chaos.
Someone close to you dies or you don't
get the promotion you were looking for
some dream collapses on you.
You discover a new fault that you were
never aware of before and you fall into
this chaotic state.
And in that chaotic state,
that's the underworld of mythology and
one of the suburbs of the,
of the underworld,
the most horrific suburb of the
underworld is hell.
Because when you go into the underworld
in chaos,
it's easy to become desperate and then
angry and then vengeful and then
murderous.
And that that happens to people with a
tremendous,
tremendous frequency.
If you haven't observed that in your own
life,
you haven't watched your own interior
interior landscape with,
with any degree of accuracy.
And so that cyclicality is,
is built into everything and it's the
structure of,
it's the structure of being that's the
right way to think about it.
And okay.
No,
I,
I think the optimistic part of that is
that there is a spiral upward as far as
I can tell her.
At least there can be.
And you get some sense of that when,
when you participate in your own life,
in the sense that you've found a good
direction and that's,
that's in viewing you with a sense of
positive meaning.
And I really regard,
I don't regard positive meaning as a
epic,
phenomenal manifestation of a deeper
material reality.
I don't believe that's true at all.
I believe that there is nothing more
real than that sense of,
of engaged meaning.
I think your nervous system has actually
evolved to tell you when you're in the
right place at the right time.
It's something that informs you.
It's literally beyond your census,
but,
but it's absolutely central to proper
being.
You can tell when you're engaged with
the world property because all of a
sudden the world becomes worthwhile
around you.
And that's,
that's,
that's not an illusion we'd been taught
for so long.
That meaning is some sort of illusion or
an epi phenomenon.
I think it's absolutely central and
certainly no one ever thinks that
suffering is an epithet.
Nominate everyone acts as if their own
suffering is the most real thing there
is.
And so,
and a no wonder.
So if you experience something that
enables you to transcend that suffering
or to justify it in your own life,
which is that sense of meaningful
engagement,
why wouldn't you regard that as even
more real than pain?
The only thing more real than pain is
that which can transcend it and you can
experience that in your own life.
You do that all the time when you were
in the right place at the right time.
It's a real thing.
And I also think that's the place that
truth puts you well now,
how that relates to the cyclicality.
Well that's the pathway out of it.
You know,
life is order,
chaos,
reestablishment of order.
And you could say,
well,
you're the order.
Or You could say you're the chaos and
lots of people or the chaos,
or maybe you're even at Denison of hell
inside that chaos,
or you're the reestablished order and
all of those things are reasonable
things to be.
But the most reasonable thing to be is
the thing that constantly moves along
that pathway ever upwards.
Like,
like that staircase at the back,
which is what that represents.
It's that spiral upwards.
You know that leads us up into the
beyond.
That's the stairway to heaven and that
cyclicality and and it's,
it's,
it's a genuine thing and you,
you know it but you don't know you know
it.
And some of these stories,
the icons that Jonathan produces in
these stories that we've been talking
about her are humanities attempts to
make that pattern articulate and all
we've really managed so far is to
capture that image and story.
We haven't enabled to make it fully
articulate,
but the time for that I would say is
approaching because we need to
understand these things consciously so
that we could participate in them
properly.
Thank you.
This one I suppose would be most
appropriate for our reverend fathers.
What role does Jesus Christ and the
church play in helping us to become
more like God?
Is it possible to become like God
without this person and this
institution?
Okay.
One wants to start.
This is obviously one of the hotly
debated subjects in Church history.
It's also a major subject in the New
Testament Teaching New Testament.
This term and reading Paul recently and
whole wrestles with this question,
you know,
how is it,
under the law,
outside of the law,
how do people,
you know,
come to uh,
this sort of center of being this,
this school film into a few manatees,
potential human flourishing,
you know,
with or without Christ and I,
depending on how the is asking,
you look at different,
different answers.
But I would just recall one of the main
things from tonight,
which is that logos is inherent.
This isn't something that's been kind of
concocted and positive as some sort of
philosophical premise.
Wouldn't it be nice if we all kind of
agreed with this idea and then kind of
move towards it together?
Even if it was that it would be a good
thing.
But it's so much more fundamental than
that.
Every human va,
not just those who adhere to this
philosophy has the image of God within
them and is he is operating to some
degree or another according to the
logos.
In fact,
the eastern tradition would tend to
argue that our very existence is good
and therefore every human being is good
in so far as they exist.
If there was no goodness in us,
we would not exist.
Like the evil is eclipsing,
not uh,
actually tangible force,
not a real thing.
And so is it possible for someone
without Christ to somehow come into
touch deeply with logos within them,
therefore with Christ?
Um,
I think the argument would be ultimately
yes at them it was the best means would
be too,
to hear the Gospel proclaimed Jesus
Christ is Lord and to respond to that in
faith.
As you know,
the,
the new testament talks about,
but even apart from that,
everyone already has locals and
therefore everyone already has that
pattern etched into their very
existence.
And so that's how we could possibly see
the capacity outside of the sacramental
boundaries of the church.
People coming to a position of,
you know,
harmony would there,
would there be one of the early church
fathers?
Uh,
Saint Justin martyr refers to a,
and it picks up,
actually this is a pre socratic idea.
The,
the logos,
spare matticus the seeds of the word
which are all through creation and so
this is the fundamental essence of,
of all of reality,
not only in us but in all of creation.
So he was dealing with the fact that
people were pointing out,
well,
how come there's dying and rising gods
in all sorts of different cultures?
How come all of the things that you find
in the the the Christian faith or
already present in many myths and
cultures and so forth.
And he said,
that's brilliant.
You know,
of course they are.
This is true.
If it wasn't true,
it wouldn't be so and so in that sense,
absolutely.
What we are trying to do as Orthodox
Christians is simply live in complete
harmony with who we are as human beings.
This isn't an outside in position.
This is the very core of what we are.
This is the fulfillment and trajectory
of creation.
And so that's why it's coming back to
the earlier point about how can we have
this dialogue,
this engagement with the world,
with social sciences,
with physical sciences,
with
pure physics and mathematics.
We can do that because it all ties in
any way.
We,
we are hoping as Orthodox Christians,
we are in touch with what is
fundamentally true of creation and of
our own human person.
So,
okay,
thank you for that too.
Oh,
I suppose Dr. Peterson would be best
equipped to handle this,
uh,
are or,
or anyone our union archetypes in accord
with or opposed to Orthodox theology.
I don't know too much about what that
means,
but maybe,
yeah.
Well,
the problem
with answering that for me is that I'm
by no means an expert on Orthodox
theology.
So,
um,
but what,
from what I understand of it,
I would say
you believe that you was a student of
nature,
right?
It's something that isn't well known
about you because most of the history of
psychoanalytic thought was written by
the Friday ends and they think of you as
a student of Freud.
And of course that's true human was
really introduced to the idea of a
profound idea of the unconscious through
Freud and also at least in part to the
idea that there was an interior world of
symbols.
But at the same time,
human was a student of nature.
And you see nature announced the death
of God in the late 19 hundreds and what
he meant by that in some sense was that
he meant that the spirit of trees that
had been instantiated by Christianity
had turned against the,
the Dogma of Christianity and destroyed
it.
And what he meant by that was that the
emerging,
the emergence of science in that context
of Western culture and the elaborate
description of physical reality that he
that was developed as a consequence
ended up in apparent contradiction with
the Teresa,
with the truths of,
of our religious tradition.
And we pick the most developed truth and
let the other one go.
And nature was not celebrating that
contrary to what most people think.
I mean,
when he spoke of the death of God,
he said that it was an absolute
catastrophe and that would,
we would pay for it with millions of
lives.
And that was his prognostication for the
20th century,
which happened to come true in precisely
the manner he indicated for exactly the
reasons nature believe that we would
have to invent our own values because we
had become,
because the old values that we had lived
by had had bled themselves out and die.
But the problem with that,
and this is something you picked up on,
the problem with that is that you can't
invent your own values.
And you know that because all of you
have tried on New Year's Day to decide
that you're going to eat less than go to
the gym.
And you'd think if you could create your
own values,
you know,
being this sort of Demi God,
that as soon as you told yourself that
you would eat properly and go to the
gym,
you'd be up at six in the morning,
you know,
eating carrots and Rutabagas and then
going off to lift heavy weights.
And of course you're not,
you're sitting in your chair at night
eating cheetos and watching,
watching pornography,
you know,
so how in the world is something like
that supposed to create its own values?
You're,
you're not in control of yourself to
that degree.
And so yones answer to that problem was
to,
was essentially to,
to look partly within and partly to look
in the symbolic domain.
And what he realized as a consequence of
doing that was that there was a profound
answer to the question of the
resurrection of value.
And for him that was really the
embodiment of the pattern of,
of Christ.
That was the self as far as [inaudible]
was concerned,
there was no difference between the,
the architect will self and the symbolic
Christ.
They were the same thing as far as
anyone was concerned in so far as Christ
is the vision of the perfect man,
right?
Which is a symbolic vision.
So you could say,
well what is Christ?
And the answer to that is while Christ
is whatever you think of as the perfect
man,
now you're going to have diverse
representations of that.
So you could think about it Christ as
the totality of the visions of the
perfect man.
It's something like that.
And then that the goal of life was to
embody that as deeply as possible.
And you can also believed that the world
would transform itself around you to the
degree that you did that to uh,
to,
uh,
to an unspecified double degree.
And that's where the symbolic reality
and the historical reality unite
because,
and we know it's true.
We also know this is true.
If you look at people like Gandhi or you
look at people like saussure knits and
for example,
these are great people who stood up as
moral icons,
let's say,
in the midst of absolute chaos.
And they transform entire civilizations
by doing that,
by standing up for what they believe to
be true.
They transformed the entire world around
them.
And of course,
they're only partially perfect.
Someone like Solzhenitsyn or someone
like Gandhi or,
or perhaps someone like Nelson Mandela,
there only partial incarnations of
perfection,
but even to the degree that they were
flawed,
know they were perfectly enough so that
despite their remnant flaws,
they were able to reorganize the thing
itself around them.
And we don't know what the ultimate
limit of that is.
We really don't.
It could be that everything will align
itself around people to the degree that
they put themselves together and I
actually have,
I've had experiences that make me
convinced that that's the case.
I,
I truly believe that that's the case.
So,
and that's also what gives me some,
some belief in these strange Christian
ideas about the harrowing of Hell and
the overcoming of death.
It's like we have no idea what we could
do as individual embodiments of the
logos,
which is clearly what we are because
we're all conscious.
We have no idea what obstacles we could
overcome and what,
what massive transformations we could
undertake if we actually lived our lives
properly.
God only knows what we could get rid of.
We could get rid of malaria,
we could get rid of schistosomiasis and
the Guinea worm.
Those are going to be gone soon.
Anyways,
polio,
we're going to get rid of hunger.
Maybe we can get rid of death.
Maybe we can get rid of hell.
Who knows?
And I know I'm certainly someone who
believes that hell is real because I've
read enough of the accounts of what
happened in the 20th century to know
precisely that it's as real as the most
warped imagination can possibly make it.
And that's plenty real enough for me.
So
well,
so I would say humans vision is very
much in keeping as far as I can
understand with the central traditions
of the Orthodox Church,
because he believed that it was the
highest moral duty of the,
of the awake soul to participate in
manifestation of the self.
That's,
and that's this union of things that the
Jonathan talked about.
That's beyond duality.
It's,
it's to bring everything in you together
into this kind of harmony that then
extends beyond you into your family and,
and pass that it's musical.
That's what music represents.
That's why we find it so intensely
meaningful.
That's what music tells us.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an artwork based upon the meaning
of pattern and it,
and it infuses everyone.
You know what it's like to listen to
music.
Even the darkest punk rocking our
anarchist atheist is overwhelmed with
the glory of God when he listens to his
punk rock music.
So yeah.
Okay.
Just a quick comment on that.
Um,
going back to the central part of that
question,
which is about archetypes and with her
they're the same,
same thing.
I would
largely agree with that point.
Uh,
to the extent to which anyone is in
touch with the logos within them,
they are going to be in touch with
fundamental archetypes and those would
be the same at the church.
Fathers refer us to and and so forth.
The one element that,
and it's kind of relates to the previous
question about can you do this without
Christ?
The thing which is the possibly the
unique elements of Christian faith,
Eh,
it's not love.
Love is what defines Christianity.
In fact,
love can be found throughout the world.
It's more hope and what I know about
young,
which isn't all that much,
but absolutely the archetypes are there.
We'll go with that.
Does he come with the same level of hope
that we would as authors?
I don't know.
I mean,
sometimes you wonder whether the Coteau
Vasquez,
the descent kind of leads us to a hell
where we inhabit without hope and rather
with despair.
Can we back to that point about a
archimandrites software?
Knee puts your mind in hell,
but don't despair.
Another was have hope.
So is it possible to have that hope
without ultimately what we have,
which is the cross and the message of
the cross as an archetype is that we
stare into the depths of darkness and
death and we proclaim light in life.
In fact,
you know that's what Jesus himself says
when he refers us back to the old
testament to when the people of Israel
were dying in the wilderness,
having come out with Moses and they're
grumbling because they said we,
if only we were back in Egypt where we
had it so good.
Of course the reality of Egypt was
slavery,
but they thought,
no,
we're just going to grumble and they're
afflicted by serpents and the in God
says this most incredible thing.
Put a serpent on a stick and hold it up.
And those people that look at the
serpent look at the source of the
suffering and death will be healed.
And so Christ says,
Jesus says,
the son of man will be raised up.
So we have to look upon death and
suffering.
We have to descend into hell with light,
with light,
the light that it is never extinguished.
Come back to the prologue of Saint John.
I don't know whether that's there and
younger and I can be corrected on that,
but that's possibly the point where,
you know,
a,
a purely social science or psychological
approach might be lacking because I see
the Christian virtue,
Alex Sinners is hope because it's,
it's almost unique in its capacity to
look into everything that is so dark and
say there is yet life.
There is yet late.
So one of the things that really
affected young,
who by the way worked for the American
government,
the CIA during
World War Two,
um,
sending them psychological reports on
Hitler,
um,
young meditated for a very long period
of time on what happened in Nazi Germany
and young's the dictum that he derived
from his l chemical studies was in
[inaudible] tour,
which I'm probably saying wrong,
but it means the thing you want most
will be will be found the place you at
least one look.
And so for young you,
cause one of the questions you might ask
yourself is that if enlightenment is
possible,
let's say if union with the self as
there's some sort of mystical
transcendence.
Why in the world aren't we just all that
way?
What's the barrier?
It's like,
well,
we could be way better.
Well why not just do it then if it's
just right there ahead of us.
But,
but the answer to that is I think is
something like you cannot conceive of
how good a human being might be until
you can conceive of how evil a human
being can and will be.
And that means to encounter in yourself,
the Nazi that the prison guard,
the Auschwitz Guard to understand fully
that there is no difference between you
and the people who were killing children
in the Nazi death camps that you,
and that's that encounter with hell.
That's literally that encounter with
hell.
You're a dentist and of hell.
Insofar as you're capable of that and
you are capable of that and there isn't
anything I think that can scare you
straight,
except that knowledge you can be,
you can be and are a vessel that can be
used for absolute evil and you would
participate in it,
you would participate in it.
And so for young,
the pathway to,
it's like Dante,
you don't get to paradise before you go
to the lowest levels of hell.
Right?
Right.
At the bottom where betrayal lurks for
Dante,
that was the worst of all sins.
And so it's a terrifying process.
I tried to teach my students in my maps
of meaning class,
which is the opposite of the safe space
as far as I'm concerned.
I,
and I mean that technically,
I truly do mean that.
I tried to convince my students,
I try to get them to meditate on the
fact that they're that Damn Nazis.
Really?
Because what is it?
It's,
what is it?
The Germans like come on.
Really?
No,
obviously not.
It's people.
And so the pathway to paradise is
through hell and that's,
it's no wonder no one goes there.
I mean,
who wants to go there?
No one.
Well,
if you don't go there voluntarily,
you'll go there accidentally.
So it's better to go there voluntarily
because then you can go with hope.
You can say,
I can withstand this.
Maybe I can find a light at the end of
the tunnel.
A question for Mr Pojo.
Uh,
you have spoken in the past about the
contradictory
nature of symbols.
For example,
water represents both healing and
dangerous chaos.
Can you speak about how we can resolve
this apparent contradiction and to
follow up,
how does this apply to the relationship
between the internal mental world and
the external material world?
You might have to repeat the second part
of that question after I answer the
first part.
Um,
um,
I think,
I mean,
I,
I've been,
one of the things that has,
as you said,
that I've been thinking a lot about is
the,
is the duality of symbols.
Um,
every,
every image,
every symbol has like a dark and a light
light side.
And you can see it when you read the
Bible,
when you read the stories or even when
you look at icons or when you look at
images and,
um,
yeah,
the,
um,
it has to do with,
with,
with this idea of a,
of a cent or this idea of moving up
because,
um,
what's important when we're in on the
spiritual journey is the direction that
we're facing.
It's at,
it's not so much where we are.
Like if you can imagine the ascent of
the world or of ourselves up to God as a
ladder,
which is how often it's represented in,
in,
in Orthodox icons as this ladder that we
ascend towards God.
Um,
you could be pretty high up the ladder,
but if you fall,
there's no point,
right?
The idea is to ascend.
And so all of the symbols that we see in
m
in the Bible have those two sides.
And water is a,
is a perfect example in the old
testament,
all through the old tests,
old testament water is an image of
death,
um,
in the flood.
Um,
and then the crossing of the Red Sea
crossing of the Jordan,
he's,
he's constantly this symbol of death.
But the key to resolving the a duality
of symbolism is Christ.
He is always the key to all the stories
I believe.
And so when you look at the story of
Christ and you see how he takes let's
say,
the dark side of a symbol and he flips
it over and then makes it into something
else.
So that's the mystery,
let's say,
of baptism.
You know,
why,
why would we have to be baptized?
I mean,
it's a very strange that this flood,
you know,
this Red Sea that the Egyptians were
drowned in.
Why would we have to be baptized?
Well,
it's because the Christ takes this death
and changes into,
he changes it into a process of let's
say washing or a process of
purification.
And so the same symbol,
which is,
which is death,
can also be a symbol of washing.
Um,
so,
so it's the same with fire.
Fire is the perfect example.
I mean,
we look at icon,
you'll see fire and hell.
Then you'll see fire coming from the sky
as the manifestation of the Holy Spirit.
So how,
what does that mean?
Um,
and so it's the same thing.
Let's say you,
you,
you see fire as division.
Well,
there's a negative division,
which is the division in which we
scatter ourselves and we're,
and we're,
we're consumed.
But there's another type of division
that say the division of Pentecost,
which is the division which embodies the
multiplicity of how God manifests
himself in the world.
And so it just depends on which side you
take each symbol.
So I hope that answers that question.
What was the second part again?
Don't think about,
okay.
Yeah,
I think I understand.
I think I understand what that,
what that means.
Um,
I think it did well.
It is my real,
my belief that symbolism is anchored in
experience.
And I don't think that most symbols are
not just these abstract things that that
float above us.
So for example,
um,
a good example would be,
for example,
the mountain you,
we see in the Old Testament,
we have this sense that Moses ascends
the mountain and then encounters God.
And then we see it repeated over and
over in,
in the patterns of the stories where
Christ ascends a heel or a sends a
mountain and then something happens.
There's a revelation on the,
on this mountain.
And you think like,
well that's strange,
right?
I mean,
why would you want,
what does the amount and have to do with
anything?
Um,
and so I think the key is to
understanding a lot of symbolism is to
kind of see it as,
as an,
as an experience.
And so if you ask yourself,
for example,
what happens when I go up a mountain?
Just physically,
what happens as you go up a mountain,
you,
the,
the base of the mountain,
which is the large,
this huge thing starts to refine itself.
And then it starts to become smaller and
smaller and smaller.
And that up to you get to the point and
then everything is one.
And then if you stand at the top of a
mountain and you look around when you
were at the bottom of the mountain,
all you can see is the trees and that
are right next to you.
And you can see a very particular part
of the world.
But if you ascend to the top of a
mountain,
then you have this vision of everything.
Um,
and so the symbolism of the mountain,
which is found in the Bible and the
Gospel in the icons is akin to the,
the,
the phenomenological reality of that
thing.
So we often,
it's difficult for us to get that
because we're so caught up in a
scientific vision of the world that it's
difficult to understand the symbolism.
But if you,
if you just put yourself in the position
of someone who does something or someone
like,
water's the same,
I mean water would,
would we do with water.
We wash ourselves with water and what,
what is washing?
Washing is removing all the external and
dead things that we have on our hands.
So that we are purified.
Well that's,
that's one of the symbol.
That's one of the,
the,
the symbols of baptism.
So,
yeah.
So I think,
I hope that explains that
this question isn't addressed to anyone
in particular.
So anyone wanting to answer can do.
So,
um,
I'd like to hear your thoughts on the
concept of free will.
As many as many of the modern atheist
believe that free will is an illusion.
Uh,
according to their belief in mature in
materialism.
How does one reconcile freewill with an
omniscient God who knows the end from
the beginning who knows your future and
created you such that you were compelled
to realize it?
So believe it or not,
we get this question all the time.
We get this question from teens,
believe this.
It's the perennial question.
You know,
if God knows what's going to happen
cause he does,
if he,
if God is everywhere and fills all
things,
he is past,
present and future,
then how can you have freewill?
And then of course all of those other
implications,
right?
So know if,
if I don't have freewill or if God knows
what I'm going to do in the end.
And then does he create some people too
to go to hell or it could be away from
him or not,
you know,
reach union with him and others.
And if so,
then how can it be love and all these
other things.
So,
um,
I think the fundamental misunderstanding
is I would say the concept of time of a,
of creation itself.
So the idea that God,
we think as human beings in a linear
way,
right?
We have no other way of thinking.
So we have a beginning,
we have a president and then we have an
end.
And this is the way the world works and
moves in one direction.
Um,
we have no concept of God's reality and
the idea of being outside of time,
we have no concept of that.
We wouldn't even know how to begin to
think about that if,
if we tried and people have tried.
Um,
the easiest analogy I guess for example,
that I could,
I could give would be,
um,
the idea of perspective and what do we
mean by that?
Let's say I'm the camera person here,
right?
And I'm watching this kind of whole
event unfolding,
um,
after it's happened.
So it's,
it's been videotaped,
right?
And somebody else can watch this and
they can watch this event and they can
forward,
they go back and they can back to see
something that they really liked or
something that they forgot or they can
fast forward to the end and see how it
all turned out.
Um,
the person who is watching that,
who is removed from that reality,
uh,
they can see what's going on and what's
not going on.
They can jump ahead in the past,
but they don't cause it.
Uh,
it's just their perspective is
different.
So this idea,
and of course this is kind of a crude
analogy,
um,
of course it's much more complex than
that.
And it's much more nuanced than that.
And,
uh,
and,
and of course we would,
we would leave at least as Orthodox
Christians is that God is,
is,
is much more,
um,
permeates all things and is working in
people's lives.
Um,
but there is a strange paradox between
free will,
the idea that we have the choice whether
we want to follow God to believe in him,
uh,
or to believe rather than ourselves.
And I think,
uh,
as professor [inaudible] said,
you know,
the reality of the hell that many of us
live in and the reality of the hell that
has been created by societies and
civilizations all over the world is a
proof of the reality of freewill proof.
Um,
at least for people who believe in God.
Now,
if you don't believe in God,
different story and then you would say,
well,
that's not proof of anything except that
we're just,
we're just animals living on this planet
and there's no meaning to anything.
But if there's a god and there are still
horrible things happening,
we'll either that God is,
you know,
an evil being or rather that we have the
free will not to believe in him,
not to follow him,
not to do his will.
Um,
and,
and that may seem like a horrible,
horrible thing for God to give to us.
You know,
this idea of free will.
Um,
and yet it is also the greatest thing,
the greatest thing because it's not only
the idea of us avoiding suffering or US
avoiding sin or US avoiding the evil
that we created within the world,
but is the idea of the,
you,
the idea that through our own sin and
through our own difficulties,
we somehow find meaning.
And we,
and we come up on the other side.
So,
um,
I,
I don't know how much better I can,
can try to explain it.
It's a,
it's a complex thing,
but
so in the mythological world,
I would say there are three continually
intertwined causal elements.
One of one is consciousness.
You could say that's the logos.
One is the interpretive structure within
which that logo's exists.
And that's the framework that you used.
Organize yourself cognitively within the
world,
your point of view.
And then there's the world itself,
the natural world.
Let's say those three things are always
in interplay and they're each given
causal primacy.
Um,
you see this echoed in popular culture
motifs and I think Pinocchio is a very
good example of that where Pinocchio has
it farther.
And that's tapatio who's his creator?
And he's a,
so we're very deterministic sort of
creature and he has a mother and that's
the blue fairy that comes down from
heaven who's really f a figure of the
vitality of nature.
And so Pinocchio is portrayed in the
movie as child of nature and culture,
which is of course how we're portrayed
scientifically.
But,
but there's a third element in that
movie,
which is really what drives the plot
forward,
which is Pinocchio's capacity to make
choices.
And that's his consciousness.
And that's also what elevates him above
the status of deterministic puppet.
Now you might say,
well,
there's no evidence that we're not
deterministic.
And I could say,
well,
that's fine because there's also no
evidence that we are deterministic.
So we can leave that as a draw,
but we certainly treat each other as if
we have freewill.
We treat ourselves as if we have free
will.
We even those of us who regard each
other as deterministic,
believe that or has determined to
believe that in their own actions,
they're going to be perfectly irritated
at whatever choices you make that happen
to infringe upon them.
And they're going to act towards you as
if you're an agent with free will.
So they can say they regard people as
deterministic,
but they don't act it out.
So I don't believe that they believe it.
And I also don't believe that you can
produce a functional society without
having something like that at its basis.
And I've never seen any evidence of a
functional society being produced with
that,
without that as a metaphysical
presupposition.
So,
but there's something more crucially
crucial involved here too,
is that
in order to accept the inevitability of
determinism and human action,
you have to accept the presupposition
that consciousness is nothing but an
empath phenomena of a deeper material
reality.
And first of all,
we do not know that.
We certainly do not know that what we
know about consciousness scientifically,
you could put in a thimble and still
have enough room for another thimble.
We know nothing about it.
It's a mystery.
We have not cracked at all.
And people have been battling away
pretty hard on it from a scientific
perspective for the last 40 years since
it's become in vogue again.
And I don't think we've moved forward a
little bit.
And then finally,
so it's a mystery.
And,
and,
and I,
I don't think there's any evidence
whatsoever that it isn't.
I read Dan Dennett spit book on
explaining consciousness and it does
nothing of the sort.
It explains it away.
And that's that.
And many critics have made the same
comment.
But I also think that phenomenologically
speaking,
it is the case that we seem to encounter
the world as a field of possibility from
which we extract out choices.
You know,
you think,
well,
when I talked to you about your future,
I mean,
you know what your future is.
It's a branching set of pathways,
which you can envision because you,
you can envision the future.
It's one of the very strange things
about being human.
It's a branching set of pathways of
possibilities and you can pick from
among them.
And I do believe that's what you're
doing is I do believe that the world is
a well of possibility and potential and
that you interact with it by choice and
transform it,
it within your limited power into what
you wanted to be.
And,
and I don't think there's any evidence
to the contrary.
And besides determinism is a,
is a scientific philosophy that probably
lost it's vogue in about 1850.
So,
you know,
there's no,
there's just no reason to from a
scientific perspective to describe human
beings as deterministic creatures.
There's no evidence for it.
So we're partly determined obviously,
because there's lots of things we can't
do,
but that does not by any stretch of the
imagination mean we're fully determined
yet.
So,
yeah.
Can I just add to that that,
I mean,
first of all,
that's a thoroughly Orthodox answer.
I have to say.
Um,
we only can deal with what we have in
front of us.
I mean,
picking up on Jonathan's point earlier
about experience and our our own going
forward with the church fathers tell us
the contrary to this scientific notion
of,
you know,
time moving forward at a kind of regular
rate or anything that we might have
conceived in our minds.
It actually,
each infinitesimally small moment of our
existence is pregnant with infinite
possibility and so it's precisely what
has just been set that we have that
within our grasp.
If only we have the eyes to see it,
the only we have the hearts and minds
oriented to that,
the logos guiding us then I mean the
church fathers talk about the fact that
we can actually experience infinity.
Okay.
In the tiniest of moments.
That's what fails.
This is all about,
that's what coming into contact with
uncreated energies is all about.
In the,
in the eastern spiritual tradition,
that time and space are elastic.
We knew that before Einstein ever even
was born and that's what we have in
front of us.
So let's not get into philosophical
arguments about how God works and how he
sees his precisely other Ted's points.
I mean that's irrelevant.
What we know is that every tiny,
tiny moment of every day and every space
of this macro cosmos is the possibility
of encountering the infinite and that
that's what we have to reach forward and
grasp.
And that's what our whole tradition is
about.
And so absolutely,
it is our position on that point.
So we don't get into debates about
predestination and,
and,
and not,
it's irrelevant to us.
We just need to grab a hold of God where
he is,
which is right now in this moment,
in this space as we are.
Yeah.
Thank you very much father,
and thank you very much to each and
every one of our panelists.
Uh,
could I just get a round of applause for
all of you
to conclude this night?
Thank you to absolutely everyone for
coming.
I hope we've managed to learn a lot.
This has been recorded.
So just in case this was too much
information to take in,
which is certainly was for me,
it will be available at some point or
another.
So once again,
thank you all for coming out.